programming throwdown episode 96 continuous integration with rob zuber take it away jason hey everybody i'm here with rob zuber cto of circle ci and we're going to be talking all about Take it away, Jason. tell us before we jump into continuous integration and testing and all that tell us sort of what kind of led you down this road what sort of your background and and how did you end up CTO of CircleCI? Yeah I'll try to make that a short story I've been in the industry quite a while so a few different points that I would make along the trail. So I grew up in Toronto. I went to school at a college called Queen's University and studied engineering physics, graduated, went into manufacturing of all things, was working on computers stuff. And then some friends of mine started a company in the late 90s, you know,-com boom, and they said, hey, we need more people.
Programming Throwdown 第 96 期：与 Rob Zuber 探讨持续集成。Jason，请开始吧。嘿，大家好，我和 CircleCI 的 CTO Rob Zuber 在一起，我们将深入探讨所有相关内容。请开始吧，Jason。在进入持续集成、测试以及所有这些话题之前，先告诉我们是什么引领你走上这条道路的？你的背景是什么？你是如何成为 CircleCI 的 CTO 的？好的，我会尽量长话短说。我在这个行业待了很长一段时间，所以我想指出沿途的几个不同节点。我在多伦多长大，在皇后大学（Queen's University）学习工程物理，毕业后进入了制造业，从事计算机相关的工作。后来，90 年代末，也就是互联网泡沫时期，我的一些朋友创办了一家公司，他们说：“嘿，我们需要更多人手。”
Literally, nobody really – that wasn't a known thing at the time. And so anybody they knew that they thought they could convince to come and work for nothing, they were interested in. So that was basically – that's how I got into software. I just showed up, and they were totally tolerant of my ignorance because I just needed to learn some things and they just needed you know they needed people um and I give you I've heard crazy stories about the dot-com era I mean did they give you like a Porsche on your first day or something like that I think that's dot-com California uh dot-com dot-com Toronto was much more reserved we were like one of two startups in the city or something like that. And in fact, so my back company was eventually acquired by a company down here in the Bay Area,
说实话，当时没人真正了解这些。所以，只要是他们认识且能说服过来免费工作的人，他们都感兴趣。这基本上就是我进入软件行业的方式。我只是出现了，他们完全包容我的无知，因为我需要学习一些东西，而他们正好需要人手。嗯，我听过很多关于互联网泡沫时代的疯狂故事，他们第一天有没有给你一辆保时捷之类的东西？我想那是加州的互联网泡沫。多伦多的互联网泡沫要保守得多，我们当时大概是城里仅有的两家初创公司之一。事实上，我的那家公司后来被湾区的一家公司收购了，
which is why I ended up moving. So now I live in the Bay Area. I've been here since 2000 when we were acquired. But I actually, I didn't really start out doing software as a result. I was more, at the time I ran a team that we called Systems Engineering. I think four iterations later, we'd call that SRE, something along those lines. I spent a lot of time at data centers. I think most people don't know what a data center is anymore because they just let AWS and Google do that for them. Yeah, actually, I'd love to hear a description of a data center. I've actually never been in one.
这就是我搬到这里的原因。所以我现在住在湾区，自 2000 年被收购以来就一直住在这里。但实际上，我并不是一开始就从事软件开发。当时我管理着一个我们称为“系统工程”的团队。我想四次迭代之后，我们可能会称之为 SRE（站点可靠性工程）之类的东西。我花了很多时间在数据中心。我想大多数人现在已经不知道什么是数据中心了，因为他们只是让 AWS 和 Google 代劳。是的，实际上，我很想听听对数据中心的描述。我从来没进去过。
I mean, it's just like this ephemeral thing to me well ironic given that i have i'm getting over a cold right now the one thing i can tell you about a data center is i've never gone into one and not gotten sick really because i would always find myself standing next to well two things would happen one um it was usually under some kind of great stress like all-nighters whatever whatever because we were trying to roll something out or do some huge migration and deploy a new data center uh i would you know we'd fly down to usually somewhere in virginia you know kind of like us east one is in virginia i think that's probably built of all the old data centers that we used to use yeah and uh and you'd spend days straight in a cage full of computers that are really hot
对我来说，这就像是一个虚无缥缈的东西。嗯，考虑到我刚从感冒中恢复，这很有讽刺意味。关于数据中心，我能告诉你的一件事是，我每次进去都会生病。真的，因为我总是发现自己站在……好吧，会有两件事发生。第一，通常是在某种巨大的压力下，比如通宵工作，无论是因为我们试图推出什么东西，还是进行大规模迁移，或者部署一个新的数据中心。我会飞往通常在弗吉尼亚州的某个地方，你知道，比如美国东部一区（US East 1）就在弗吉尼亚，我想那可能是用我们过去使用的所有旧数据中心建造的。是的，你会连续几天待在一个装满计算机的笼子里，那里非常热。
and so on one side you know you have all this heat pouring out at you and on the other side the air conditioning is coming in trying to cool or like i mean this is like forced air cooling systems and your body at least for me my body was always just like what are you doing to me right now i haven't slept i haven't eaten't eaten. And on one side, I'm freezing cold. And on the other side, I'm boiling hot and invariably, and it's like recycled air and all this stuff. Yeah, so someone explained this to me. There's a gentleman that I work with and he said,
所以，一边是你感受到所有热量喷涌而出，另一边是空调试图降温，或者说，这是强制空气冷却系统。至少对我来说，我的身体总是会觉得：“你现在在对我做什么？”我没睡觉，也没吃东西。一边冷得要命，另一边又热得沸腾。而且总是这样，空气是循环的，还有所有这些东西。是的，所以有人向我解释过这一点。我的一位同事说，
and correct me if I'm getting this messed up, but the individual machines, so the data center, you know, they don't just buy, they don't go to Best Buy to buy machines. I mean, it's like they have so many that they're all custom and the machines don't have fans. And that's because they design the entire data center is basically one giant fan. It's just errors moving across the machines. And so they don't need their own fans.
如果我记错了请纠正我，但那些独立的机器，也就是数据中心，他们不只是去百思买（Best Buy）买机器。我的意思是，他们拥有的机器太多了，全都是定制的，而且机器没有风扇。这是因为他们设计的整个数据中心基本上就是一个巨大的风扇。空气只是在机器间流动，所以它们不需要自己的风扇。
Yeah. Well, again, I also am someone who just buys machines from, you know, AWS and Google and whatever now. So a lot has changed like we we were buying sort of one u2u a u is a rack unit but like like thin pizza box type machines at the time um and they would have had individual cooling okay now now you tend to buy more blades and that's been a thing for a long time so you buy a chassis and each each actual computer is just like a card that you slot in. And then it has something in it called a backplane or I think it's a midplane backplane. Doesn't matter. And they slot into that to get power and cooling and stuff like that. And also now I think a lot of data centers use liquid cooling even. So there's, you know, because you get, this is the one thing I might remember from my engineering physics degree, but like you get better thermal transfer right through
是的。好吧，同样，我现在也是一个只从 AWS 和 Google 等地方购买机器的人。所以很多事情都变了。我们当时购买的是 1U 或 2U（U 是机架单元）的机器，就像薄薄的披萨盒那样的机器，它们会有独立的冷却系统。现在你倾向于购买更多的刀片服务器，这种情况已经持续很长时间了。所以你买一个机箱，每一台实际的计算机就像一张插进去的卡。然后它里面有一个叫背板（backplane）或中板（midplane）的东西。没关系。它们插进去以获得电力和冷却等。而且现在我想很多数据中心甚至使用液冷。所以，你知道，因为你得到了……这是我从工程物理学位中可能记得的一件事，但你通过固体接触获得的导热效果比空气吹过要好。
like solid contact than just air blowing over. Um, so if they can cool the chassis and then whatever, like transfer that in, of course, uh, I don't know if you've ever seen a heat sink on top of a chip, but those are designed for air cooling, right? You can't like blow over the heat sink, but, but, um, so I don't know exactly all the details of how this stuff is built. They've done a lot to cool. I mean, power, I was actually looking at this because we run a lot of compute at CircleCI.
所以如果他们能冷却机箱，然后无论怎样，把热量传导出去……当然，我不知道你是否见过芯片上的散热片，但那些是为空气冷却设计的，对吧？你不能直接吹过散热片，但是……所以我不知道这些东西是如何建造的所有细节。他们做了很多降温工作。我的意思是，电力，我实际上在研究这个，因为我们在 CircleCI 运行大量的计算。
We'll get to that later. And so we've actually looked at, you know, like, are we at the point where we need to own some of our own hardware? And we do for some very small specific cases. And as I started to look at how do you even do data centers these days, you know, there are some that where the model is just you pay for power. Because, you know, providing power and providing cooling is what really matters in there. Like, they don't care how much space you're using.
我们稍后再谈这个。所以我们实际上研究过，比如，我们是否到了需要拥有自己硬件的地步？对于一些非常小且特定的情况，我们确实拥有。当我开始研究如今如何构建数据中心时，你知道，有些模式是你只需要支付电费。因为，你知道，提供电力和冷却才是那里真正重要的。他们不在乎你占用了多少空间。
They care how much power you're drawing, right? Because, like, that's where the real sort of expense is going. Yeah, that makes sense. It's usually out way out in the middle of nowhere, like IOR or something. So yeah, space is not an issue. Right, exactly, exactly. So yeah, I did a lot of that at the time.
他们在乎你消耗了多少电力，对吧？因为那是真正的开支所在。是的，这很有道理。它通常在荒郊野外，比如爱荷华州之类的。所以空间不是问题。没错，正是如此。所以我当时做了很多那方面的工作。
I was doing, you know, I was kind of a DBA and like focusing on actually build systems. Interestingly enough, first thing I did when I showed up was write a build script and figure out how we're going to get our code into production as quickly as possible, even in 98 or whatever year that was. So we were acquired and moved to San Francisco, did a bunch of different things at the acquiring company, including some product management, some sort of like prototyping and like strategy work and things like that. Honestly, some sales type stuff like going to visit customers and help close big deals by helping them understand our technology. And only sort of, I think, 07, I finally left there and went to a company actually as a CTO. And ironically, at that point, really spent my days writing software.
我当时是数据库管理员（DBA），专注于构建系统。有趣的是，我刚到那里时做的第一件事就是编写构建脚本，并弄清楚如何尽快将代码投入生产，即使是在 98 年或那样的年份。后来我们被收购并搬到了旧金山，在收购公司做了很多不同的事情，包括一些产品管理、原型设计、战略工作等等。老实说，还有一些销售类的工作，比如去拜访客户，通过帮助他们了解我们的技术来帮助达成大额交易。直到 07 年左右，我才终于离开那里，去了一家公司担任 CTO。讽刺的是，在那一点上，我真的把时间花在编写软件上了。
Because at a tiny company, that's what you do as a CTO, right? Like you're a CTO in name, but you're kind of a team lead. And you're just, you know, the most senior engineer working on building the product. Yeah, that makes sense. It was like a 10 person company, right? So was that sort of a kind of a shock? Because you had probably done less and less coding over time. As you say, you've been doing sales and you've been trying to sort of run that larger company.
因为在一家小公司，这就是你作为 CTO 所做的事情，对吧？你名义上是 CTO，但你实际上是团队负责人。你只是最资深的工程师，致力于构建产品。是的，这很有道理。那是一家 10 人的公司，对吧？所以那是一种冲击吗？因为随着时间的推移，你可能越来越少写代码了。正如你所说，你一直在做销售，并试图管理那家更大的公司。
And then now you end up as CTO of, let's say, I don't know, a three, five-person company. And so you have to get back on the saddle, right? Was it sort of hard to ride that bike again? Well, what's interesting is honestly, like I have a pretty unusual career path. I would say that was when I first started writing software. Oh, that's true, okay. So I basically, up until that point,
然后你最终成为了一家，比如说，三五人公司的 CTO。所以你必须重新回到岗位上，对吧？重新骑上那辆自行车很难吗？嗯，有趣的是，老实说，我的职业道路很不寻常。我会说那是我第一次开始编写软件的时候。哦，那是真的，好吧。所以基本上，在那之前，
I had done a bunch of sort of like prototyping and things like that, but like sitting down and writing production software every day as my job, that was the first time that i really did that because i was always this jack of all trades pulling things together you know building a prototype and then flying to a customer and selling it for crazy amounts of money and then handing it off to an engineering team to say okay make this real uh which is that's good living by the way if you could do that yeah that that sounds really awesome i mean it sounds also like a huge responsibility you had a similar issue where um one of the sales
我做过很多原型设计之类的事情，但像每天坐下来编写生产软件作为我的工作，那是我第一次真正这样做，因为我一直是个多面手，把事情拼凑在一起，你知道，构建一个原型，然后飞到客户那里以疯狂的价格卖掉它，然后把它交给工程团队说：“好吧，把它变成现实。”顺便说一句，如果你能做到这一点，那生活过得不错。是的，那听起来真的很棒。我的意思是，这也听起来像是一项巨大的责任。你遇到过类似的问题吗？其中一位销售工程师，我们有这个系统，它是一个嵌入式系统，所以想象一下机器人，他们想在这个机器人中做一些更复杂的 AI。销售工程师说：“哦，没关系。我们可以以 30 赫兹而不是 60 赫兹运行它。”这太荒谬了。就像整个机器人，所有的传感器，一切都是为了以 60 赫兹运行而设计的。但他却说：“哦，别担心。”这有点像我们会在后期修复它。我们所有的工程师，当我们听到这个时，
engineers we had this system and it was an embedded system um so think of like a robot right and and and the they wanted to do some more complicated AI in this robot. And the sales engineer said, oh, it's fine. We can just run it at 30 hertz instead of 60 hertz. And so that's just ridiculous. It's like the entire robot, all the sensors, everything had been designed to run at 60 hertz. But he's like, oh, don't worry about it. It's sort of like we'll fix it in post. And all of us engineers, when we heard that,
我们都在想：“我们要怎么办？”所以你处于这样一种情况，你可能可以构建一个原型。你真的必须知道后端实际上什么是可能的，对吧？你必须与你的工程团队保持良好的关系。是的，完全正确。我觉得我把它说得比实际情况更糟了，
we're like, what are we going to do? I mean, and so you have this situation where you could potentially build a prototype. You really have to know, like, what's actually possible, you know, in the back end, right? You have to have a good relationship with your eng team. Yes, exactly. And I feel like I'm making it sound a little worse than it was
因为我确实与工程团队保持着那种关系。是的，完全正确。我觉得我把它说得比实际情况更糟了，因为我确实与工程团队保持着那种关系。我非常了解我们的代码库。当我构建原型时，我使用我们的生产代码来构建它们，比如修改我们的生产代码来做某些事情，只是做得非常快，并说：“看，我知道这不是我们想交付给客户的东西，但我们能够赢得业务。”
because I did have that relationship with the engine team. Yes, exactly. And I feel like I'm making it sound a little worse than it was because I did have that relationship with the engineering team. Like I knew our code base is really, really well. When I built prototypes, I built them using our production code, like modifying our production code to do certain things, just did them very quickly and said, look, I know this isn't what we would wanna ship to a customer, but we were able to get the business.
这有点像你现在所说的 MVP（最小可行性产品），也许，相对于成品。是的，没错。虽然，好吧，你可以选择任何一种方式，因为老实说，你想扔掉其中的一部分并把它做好。但有趣的是，在这样做的时候，因为我深入研究了我们的真实代码，而且那里有一些工程师，他们的能力我可能在那之后很少见到，我通过与他们的代码合作，通过真正深入了解他们构建系统的方式，学到了很多东西。
It was sort of like what you would now call an MVP, maybe, versus a pro. Yeah, right. Although, well, you could go either way, because honestly, you wanted to throw a chunk of it out and do it well. But interestingly, in so doing, because I was deep in our real code and there were some engineers there, the likes of, like the capability of which I probably haven't seen um since or have seen rarely since i learned a lot just by working with their code by really being deep in sort of how they had built systems and spending the time
这有点奇怪，因为我无法获得他们太多的时间，我不能说：“嘿，过来和我坐在一起，向我解释这是怎么运作的。”所以我只是学习。这就像阅读大量的代码，以此来理解好的代码是如何构建的。但这确实影响了我之后很长一段时间对软件的思考方式。是的，这很有道理。它主要是 C 语言，我现在写得不多了。
and and it was kind of a weird because um i couldn't get a lot of their time i couldn't say hey come sit with me and explain to me how this works. So I just studied. It was like reading very large volumes of code as a means to understand how good code could be structured. But it definitely influenced the way that I thought about software for a long time after that. Yeah, that makes sense. It was primarily C, which I don't do a lot of anymore.
是的，没错。所以，然后我去了那里，担任了这个 CTO 的角色。结果并不是很好。我在那里待了几年。公司无法真正找到立足点。然后我开始了自己的几项事业，做了一些咨询。
Yeah, right. So yeah, so then I went in and did this, took this role as a CTO. It didn't really work out that well. I was there a couple years. The company, you know, couldn't really find traction. And then I started a couple of my own things, did some consulting.
然后 2011 年，我和另外两个人创办了一家企业，一个叫 Jonathan Ehrlich 的人，还有另一位绅士 Jim Rose。我们为那项业务工作了几年，我想是 2011 年到 2013 年底。我们建立了一个市场。那是一次很酷的经历。我们筹集了一些资金，建立了一个团队，但市场情况发生了变化。它没有成功。我们随后尝试寻找一些移动优先的方法，因为现在已经是 2013 年底了。我们尝试了一些移动优先的方法来解决我们试图解决的问题。然后我们只是，
And then 2011, I started a business with two other guys, a guy by the name of Jonathan Ehrlich and another gentleman, Jim Rose. And we worked on that business for a couple of years, I think 2011 to kind of late 2013. We built a marketplace. It was a cool experience. We raised some money, we built out a team, but things changed in the market. Um, it, it didn't work out. We then tried to find some, uh, some mobile first cause now it's late 2013. We tried some mobile first approaches to the problem we were trying to solve. And then we just,
一旦我们有了这些部分和一些移动端的专业知识，我们就开始分拆移动应用程序。就像：“也许人们会喜欢这个，也许他们会喜欢那个。”彼此完全无关。然后我们说：“哇，构建 iOS 应用程序真的很难。工具不是很好。人们并不真正了解如何在这个世界中进行测试。”我想 Rails 开发人员刚刚开始转向 iOS，因为它正在成为一种趋势。而一群 Rails 开发人员的冲击，
once we had the pieces and some mobile expertise, we just started spinning out mobile apps. Like maybe people will like this, Maybe they'll like this. Totally unrelated to each other. And then we said, wow, building iOS apps is really hard. Like the tooling is not very good. People don't really understand how to test in this world. I would say Rails developers were just starting to make the shift into iOS because it was becoming a thing. And the shock of a bunch of Rails developers
他们习惯了测试驱动开发，立即构建出规范，出现在 iOS 世界中，只是说：“有人写过测试吗？”如果你真的看看，我不知道现在是什么样子，因为我已经有一段时间没做 iOS 开发了，但如果你看看 2013、2014 年的工具，它们全都是用 Ruby 编写的。所有的测试框架，所有的驱动程序，因为这是一群来到那个世界的人的转变，他们只是说：“这里发生了什么？”所以他们不打算用 Objective-C 编写一堆桌面工具，因为那看起来工作量太大了。所以他们用 Ruby 创建了所有这些框架。你可以看出那段历史。哇。
who were like test-driven development, you skeleton out specs immediately, showing up in iOS and just saying, has anyone ever written a test? And then if you actually look at, I don't know what it's like now because I haven't done iOS development in a while, but if you look at the 2013, 2014 tooling, it's all written
这就像为你进行的一点考古工作。是的。所以 2011 年，你开始担任 CTO，对吧，第一家。所以现在是 2017 年。这是 2013、14 年。哦，13、14 年。好的，iOS 时代，对吧？是的，所以那是三年。所以，你知道，我认为很多人会放弃，你知道，会说：“好吧，这没成功。”也许他们会更早放弃。对。而你坚持了下来，这，你知道，是你的功劳，
in Ruby. All of the test frameworks, all of the drivers, because it was this shift of people who were coming to that world and they just went, what is happening here? And so they weren't about to write a bunch of desktop tooling in Objective-C because that just seemed like a lot of work. So they created all these frameworks in Ruby. And you can kind of see that history. Wow.
对吧？所以是什么让你在那个轨道上坚持下去，你知道，甚至两、三年、四年？有几件事，我们……在那个公司，我们完成了种子轮和 A 轮融资。所以我们有钱运营。我们有相信我们去尝试构建和发展的投资者。而 Facebook 在那个时候，如果你回头看看他们要去哪里，实际上他们自己也从平台转向了移动端。这确实带走了……他们改变了关于内容如何进入 Feed 的算法。有一段时间有一个滚动条，然后它就消失了。所以，老实说，我们基本上是在通过垃圾邮件来推动增长的途径，某种程度上枯竭了，我们试图让飞轮转动并达到规模的能力消失了。所以我们缩减了公司的一部分。我们把一些钱还给了投资者。但老实说，在那一点上，让我们坚持下去的是人。对。至少对我来说是这样。所以当我们进入 2014 年的时候，当我们进入 2014 年初的时候，基本上只有我们三个人，我自己，我提到的 Jim，还有另一位曾是我们早期工程师之一的工程师。
It's like a little archaeology for you. Yeah. So 2011, you started as CTO, right, of the first. And so now it's 2017. This is 2013, 14. Oh, 13, 14. Okay the for the um the the ios era right yeah and so so that's so that's three years and so what is you know i think that a lot of people out there would have would have given up you know like like would have said okay though this this didn't work out maybe they would have given up even much sooner. Right. And you persevered, which is, uh, you know, which is to your credit,
我们意识到，嘿，这些移动应用程序的工具真的很难构建。所以我们决定为 iOS 和移动端构建一个 CI/CD 平台。是的，我认为如果你有才华横溢的人，并且你们有情谊，你们互相信任，你们愿意……有才华的人，你们有情谊，你们互相信任，你们愿意牺牲。我的意思是，我看到过一种情况，有人，在我看来，他们有一家成功的初创公司，但那个人，我不知道确切的说法是什么，不是“临阵退缩”，但他们最终还是放弃了，加入了一家大公司，这让初创公司处于不利地位。所以对你来说，如果你有一个好的核心团队，即使正如你所说，市场以一种你无法控制的方式发生了变化，所以那个最初的想法你无法挽救，不，没有多少才华能挽救它。
right? So what sort of, you know, kind of what was keeping you going on, on that track, you know, even two, three, four years, a couple of things we, um, so in that company, we got through a seed round and an A round. So we had money to run. We had investors who believed in to try to build and grow. And Facebook around that time, if you go back and look at where they were headed, made a big shift away from platform and into mobile themselves, actually. And that really took away, like, they changed algorithms about how things went into the feed. There was a ticker for a while there, and then it was gone. And so the avenues, which if I'm honest, we were basically spamming to drive growth, sort of dried up and our ability to try to get the flywheel going and get to scale disappeared. So we wound down a chunk of the company. We gave some money back to investors. But honestly, at that point, the thing that kept us going is people. Right. Like for me anyway. So by the time we got to the point as we head into 2014, where we by the time we got into the beginning of 2014, there were basically three of us, myself, Jim, who I had mentioned, and then one other engineer who had been one of our early engineers.
但现在你可能拥有比进入时更强的情谊，因为你们一起构建了一些你们可以引以为豪的东西，即使你们无法在市场上，在更广阔的市场中实现它，对吧？所以这导致了这种认识，即这里有另一个我们可以解决的市场。是的，绝对。而且我想说，从之前的经验来看，无论是我在大型组织工作时，还是我加入其他初创公司时，我对人的价值相对于想法、业务或其他任何东西的理解，都已经增长了很多。所以认识到我正在与几个我们合作得非常好的人一起工作，那具有巨大的价值。我愿意接受这一点，去弄清楚我们要去做什么，而不是去某个大型组织工作之类的。
And we had realized, hey, this tooling is really hard to build these mobile apps. And so we decided to build a CICD platform for iOS and for mobile. Yeah, I think it's like if you have the talented folks and you have camaraderie, you trust each other, you're willing to, you know talented folks and you have camaraderie you trust each other you're willing to you know sacrifice i mean i saw a situation where somebody they actually had in my opinion a successful startup but that person got i don't know really what the phrase is not quite cold feet isn't the right word but they ended up kind of bailing and joining uh you know kind of a big company um and and that kind of put the startup in a bad position right so in your case if you have a good core group of people um even if as you said the the the market changed in a way that you couldn't control and so that that initial idea you just couldn't save it no No amount of talent could save it.
我的意思是，快进到今天。所以 Jim，从那个故事里，我们构建了 Distiller。我们带着那个 iOS CI/CD 能力被收购进了 CircleCI。Jim 是 CircleCI 的 CEO，我是 CTO。所以自从 2011 年初开始，我们就一直在一起工作。对。找到这一点老实说非常重要。当我看到，你知道，对于其他初创公司，人们分道扬镳的情况，有很多初创公司有很棒的想法并且正在取得成功。但创始人之间、高层人员之间的紧张关系，破坏了事情。所以找到伟大的工作关系非常重要。所以当你找到它时坚持下去，我会说这是其中的很大一部分。对于是什么让我们坚持下去的问题，就是那样，嘿，我们真的很喜欢一起工作。我们知道我们有能力解决大问题。让我们选一个大问题去解决它。是的，这完全说得通。我认为对于那些，你知道，也许他们不一定是在创办公司，但也许他们正在做一些副项目的人来说，我有一个很棒的建议，这实际上是我们以前在节目中从未说过的，
But now you could potentially even have stronger camaraderie than you did going into it because you built something together that you could be proud of even if you weren't able to pull it off in the marketplace, the broader marketplace, right? And so that kind of led to this realization that there's this there's this other market here that we could tackle. Yeah, absolutely. And I would say from some experiences prior to that, both when I was working in larger organizations, when I joined a startup in other startups, my understanding of the value of the people versus the idea, the business, you know, whatever else, um, had just grown and grown. And so recognizing that I was working with, with a couple of folks, uh, who we worked really, really well together. Um, that was of huge value. I was willing to take that and go sort out what it was we were going to do over, you know, go work at some large organization or whatever.
就是找个伙伴，找另一个人。也许如果那个人有另一个很酷的想法，你们俩都实现它们。至少这样你们有另一双眼睛，你们可以和别人一起踏上旅程。是的，完全正确。而且我的意思是，那段旅程，作为一个在两端都有过经验的人，我想我只想说它可能相当具有挑战性。媒体对那些成功的巨大组织给予了太多的赞誉，这些一夜之间的成功，老实说，是他们 10 年努力的结果。是的，没错。其中有一些非常黑暗的时期。如果你想度过难关，并且想有效地度过难关，拥有支持你的人，你们合作得很好，所有这些事情，那是一个巨大的区别。老实说，我无法想象独自一人去尝试。
I mean, you fast forward to today. So Jim, from that story, we built Distiller. We got acquired into CircleCI with that iOS CI CD capability. And Jim is the CEO of CircleCI and I'm the CTO. So we continue to work together since we started in the beginning of 2011. Right. And that's so finding that honestly is huge. And as I look at, you know, to your point of other startups where where people kind of fall
是的，这完全说得通。所以你看到了这种需求……是的，我的意思是，我记得早期的 iOS 开发和 Android 开发，基本上他们提供了这个模拟器，即使那样也不是很好。它非常慢。他们基本上就像是：“看，如果你想测试这个，在设备上运行它，直到它停止工作。”这就是他们的哲学，你看到了，你凭借你的经验说：“不，不，我认为人们不会忍受这一点。一定有更好的东西。”是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我们在尝试自己构建一些应用程序的过程中，我们只是认为这看起来不对，你知道，人们没有这种能力。而且我们之前一直在使用 CI 和 CD，之前的业务实际上是一个 Rails 应用程序，所以我们是以 CI/CD 为中心的，我们将其作为我们流程和构建的核心部分。当我们转向移动端时，我们只是认为，
out, there's a lot of startups that have great ideas and are having success. But the tension between the founders, between high level people, you know, breaks things apart. And so finding great working relationships is is huge. And so sticking with that when you find it, I would say is a big part of it to the question of what kept us going. It was that just like, Hey, we really like working together. We know that we're able to solve big problems. Let's just pick a big problem and go solve it. Yeah, that totally makes sense. I think for folks out there who are, you know, maybe they're not necessarily starting a company, but maybe they're doing some side projects. I a great piece of advice that's actually something we've never said
嗯，这看起来不是一个很好的环境。特别是，我实际上不知道现在是什么样子，但在当时，我们会花两三周时间让一个构建通过 App Store 并交到客户手中，对吧？所以当你这样做时，如果有一个问题，比如你发现是因为第二个尝试使用它的客户遇到了问题，然后又花三周时间试图发布补丁，无论如何……我的意思是，有一个加急流程，但我们仍然需要时间。是的，你知道，现在我基本上回到了云世界，你知道，如果有一个问题，我们只是修补它并发布补丁，它会立即推出。而且，你知道，几乎没关系。但是在那，在那个空间里，在……的空间里，
uh on the show before is to grab a buddy like get get someone else and uh maybe if that person has a different cool idea you both implement both of them right at least that way you have another pair of eyes and and uh you can kind of go on the journey with someone else. Yeah, totally. And I mean, that journey, like as someone who's done both ends of the spectrum, I guess I would just say it can be pretty challenging. There's a lot of great press given to the huge organizations that succeed, these overnight successes that are honestly 10 years into their process or whatever. Yeah, right. There are some pretty dark times in there. And if you if you want to get through them and you want to get through them effectively, like having people around you who, you know, support you and you work well together and all those things, that's a that's
我需要两周时间才能发布修复程序，对你的交付充满信心对你来说价值更高。是的。是的，没错。而且很多这些应用程序，App Store 中有太多的竞争，有太多人在 App Store 上做 SEO，所以如果你的应用程序有 Bug，别人会意识到你的应用程序有问题，可能会写一个类似的应用程序。我的意思是，取决于你有多少锁定，但写一个类似的应用程序，然后夺走你的整个业务。我的意思是，我在游戏领域看到过很多这种情况，你知道，这只是……你不能给游戏申请专利，没有太多的知识产权，除非它是像电影之类的商标。所以，是的，我的意思是，只要一个错误，你就会被消灭。而且，这是一个至少没有很好测试的生态系统。所以这有点像，它几乎和你之前描述的相反，市场某种程度上关闭了。这是一个你带着丰富的经验进入一个正在爆炸式增长的市场的情况。而且移动端还在变得更大。我的意思是，印度和其他国家的移动端正在进行巨大的扩张。
a huge difference. I can't even imagine trying to go it alone, honestly. Yeah, that totally makes sense. And so you saw this need to... Yeah, I mean, I remember early iOS development and Android development, and basically they provided this emulator, and even that wasn't very good. It was very slow. And they were basically like, look, if you want to test this,
是的，是的。而且我想说我们继续看到这一点。我的意思是，所以移动端一直在爆炸式增长，但现在在 CircleCI 内部也是如此。所以我们在加入 CircleCI 之前基本上做了四五个月，因为我们看到这不仅仅是移动端。但现在在 CircleCI 待了五年多，我继续看到这个投资开发者的空间，使他们能够真正成功，快速交付，将他们的想法推向市场。而这一切，你知道，“软件正在吞噬世界”，我们如何使我们的软件团队真正为我们推动竞争差异化……你知道，我们只是看着它爆发。所以我们正处于其中，这是一个非常酷的位置。
run it on a device until it stops working. That was kind of their philosophy and you saw you kind of had it had uh with your experience you kind of said no no i think i think people are not gonna not gonna put up with that there's there's gotta be something better yeah exactly i mean we we in the process again of trying to build some some apps ourselves we just thought this is this doesn't seem right you know that that people don't have this capability um and we had been we had been using ci and cd uh for like the business before was actually a rails app and so we were ci cd centric we were using that as a core part of our process and building um and as we switched to mobile we just thought,
是的，但……而且，经历过你，经历过 2000 年代初，当时每个人都说：“哇，软件开发真的很贵。让我们去找最便宜的人来构建软件。让我们把它当作一个成本中心来管理。”到 180 度大转弯，软件是我们作为一家公司如何实现差异化的方式，我们如何尽可能多地投资以用最优秀的人构建最好的软件，作为一名软件开发人员，我不得不说，看着市场上的这个周期是非常有回报的。是的，绝对。所以这是其中之一，
well, this doesn't seem like a great environment. And especially, I actually don't know what it's like now, but at the time we would spend two, three weeks getting a build approved through the app store and out into the hands of customers, right? So when you do that, and then there's a problem, like you finding out because the second customer that tries to use it runs into an issue and then spending another three weeks trying to get the patch out or whatever i mean there's there was a expedite process but we still take time yep you know we now i'm back in pretty much cloud world where you know if there's a an issue we just patch it and release the patch and it rolls out immediately. And, you know, almost doesn't matter. Um, but in that, in that space, in the space of, uh, you know,
或者我想很多产品都有这种情况，你的目标受众，所以会有一些人已经做了大量的 TDD，大量的测试驱动开发。从某种意义上说，现在你正在处理这个现任者。所以也许他们有一些自制的工具，无论他们在使用什么，对吧？然后你一直到光谱的另一端，在那里，我的意思是，我仍然知道有些人不写任何测试，你知道，他们承担着相当重要的责任。所以，如果有人来找你说：“你知道，我正在这个机器人上做这个 FPGA，或者我正在做一些非常具体的事情，为什么我应该写测试？”所以你的回应会是什么？嗯，我的意思是，我认为这是一个关于测试的一般性问题，然后在特定情况下。我猜我有一段很长的测试历史。我的意思是，实际上，当我一直回到我刚开始做系统工程之类的事情时，我也管理过一个 QA 团队。我们当时对测试的看法非常不同，对吧？这有点像，我们将编写代码，然后我们将它交给其他团队，他们会点击按钮，某种程度上，你知道，浏览所有的功能。然后最终我们会发货，而且，你知道，随着我们接近发布日，Bug 数量是否在收敛？我的意思是，那是一个非常、非常不同的时代。是的，我记得那些时光。是的，最终……对我来说，这是关于来自那些
it's going to take me two weeks to get the fix out, being really confident in your delivery is even higher amount of value for you. Yep. Yep. That's right. And a lot of these apps, there's, there's so much competition in the app store and there's so many people doing SEO on the App Store that if your app has a bug in it, someone else will realize your app has an issue, probably write a similar app. I mean, depending on how much lock-in you have, but write a similar app
日子……如果你看看那是一个漫长的软件开发进化弧线，但……这实际上是关于反馈循环，对吧？第一，所以作为一个……我们已经尝试减少所有的阶段，对吧？我们已经从瀑布式转向敏捷，这样我们以更短的增量工作，然后一直到我们测试小部分，然后我们将小部分放在客户面前。而我所看重的是，我仍然在脑海中加载了上下文，对吧？所以，在绝对理想的情况下，也许我们稍后会回到这一点，持续部署，对吧？
and just take away your entire business. I mean, I've seen it happen a lot in the in the games space where um you know it's just it's just there's you can't patent a game there's and there's not much intellectual property there unless it's some trademark like a movie or something and so yeah i mean it's just one mistake you can get wiped out um and it's and it's the it's the ecosystem that did at least didn't have very good testing. So it's kind of like, it's almost the opposite of what you described earlier where the market sort of closed. This was a case where you were coming in with a lot of experience and a market that was just exploding. And mobile is still getting bigger. I mean, there's a huge expansion in India and in other countries on mobile.
我的客户正在看到我刚刚写的东西，这很棒。这令人满足，因为我刚刚写了它，我正在为业务提供价值。但同样，如果它出了问题，我刚刚写了它，对吧？当我遇到那些时刻，我写了一些东西，我把它投入生产，然后出了问题，或者无论什么，因为有不同的数据，我没有考虑到的事情，我的
Yeah, yeah. And I would say we continue to see that. I mean, so mobile has been exploding, but also now within CircleCI. So we did that for four months, five months, basically, before we joined CircleCI because we saw this is a bigger thing than just mobile. But now having been at CircleCI over five years, I continue to see this space of investing in developers, enabling them to be really successful, delivering quickly, getting their ideas into the market. And this whole you know software is eating the world how can we enable our software teams to really drive competitive differentiation for us um you know we're just watching that blow up right and so we're in the middle of that which is a very cool place to be
反应，我发现在那种情况下通常是：“哦，对了，当然。当然我没有想到那件事，现在我知道确切去哪里修复它了。”如果我在六个月后部署该代码，有人说：“嘿，生产中发生了这种情况。”我们只会像：“这是我做的事情吗？是别人做的事情吗？我不知道。让我们花三天时间试图找出 Bug 可能在哪里。”我们会对六个月进行 git blame，并试图找出这是在哪里发生的。是的，二分查找成千上万的提交。正是如此，正是如此。
yeah but it's and and having been through you, having been around in the kind of early 2000s where everyone said, wow, software development is really expensive. Let's go find the cheapest possible people to build software. Let's manage it like a cost center to go 180 degrees to software is how we're going to differentiate as a company, how do we invest as much as possible to build the best possible software with the greatest people is, I will say as a software developer, very rewarding to watch as a cycle in the market. Yeah, definitely. So this is one of these,
所以我认为测试，测试背后的一个关键点就是更多地将其拉入，对吧？所以我正在编写代码，当谈到测试驱动开发时，我不是一个狂热者。我会为一切编写测试。绝对有这样的情况，我说：“哦，好吧，这是，
or I guess many products have this where your target audience, so there are going to be people who already do a ton of TDD, a ton of test-driven development. And in a sense, now you're dealing with this incumbent. So maybe they have some homegrown thing, whatever they're using, right? Then you have all the way on the other end of the spectrum where, I mean, I still know of folks who don't write any tests, you know who are who are you know have some pretty significant responsibility right so so if someone comes to you and says um you know like i'm doing
我完全理解这需要做什么。我认为要把它做好会有点棘手。我会写一个测试，然后我只是会迭代这个东西，直到我把它做好。”还有其他时候，测试很尴尬或奇怪，感觉就像我在到达那里之前就在巩固我的想法。我的意思是，关于这一点有很多争论，但无论哪种方式，在我工作时验证我的想法是否正确的能力，我认为是其中之一……是的，这很有道理。测试的真正好理由……是的，在某种程度上，它是客户之前的客户，所以……是的，而且我会说，有了这个，它是以两种不同方式的客户，所以
this fpga on this robot or i'm doing something very specific uh like why should i write tests right so so what what would be kind of your response to that? Well, I mean, that's an interesting question, I think, about testing in general and then in then in the specific cases. I have a I guess a long history with testing. I mean, actually, when I all the way back to when I started out and did systems engineering and stuff like that, I also ran a QA team. And we thought about testing very differently back then, right? It was sort of, we'll just, we'll write the code and then we'll give it to some other team and they'll click on buttons and sort of, you know, move through all of the capabilities. And then eventually we'll ship and it was, you know, is the bug count converging as we get closer to our release day? I mean, it was a very, very different time. Yeah, I remember those times a little bit yeah and and ultimately um for me it's about coming from those
第一，我立即得到反馈。所以同样，它是完全新鲜的。如果我写了一个 Bug 并立即捕获它，它甚至不烦人。它只是：“哦，好吧，是的，那发生了。”我会修复它，然后继续前进，而不是再次，一天、一周或一个月后。但你也成为了你的 API 的第一个消费者，对吧？或者你在为它编写测试时的设计。所以你说：“好的，我需要测试这个东西，这是我传入数据的方式，这是我获取数据的方式。这感觉真的很笨拙。也许我的设计实际上并不那么好，对吧？”
days like if you look at the that's a long arc of evolution and software development but um it's really about feedback loops right number one so as an like we've, we've tried to reduce all of the stages, right? We've gone from, you know, waterfall to agile so that we're working in shorter increments and then all the way to the point where we're testing small bits and then we're putting small bits out in front of customers. And what, what I value in that is that I still have the context loaded in my head, right? So in the absolute ideal, maybe we'll come back to this later, continuous deployment, right?
也许我会对如何构建代码有不同的思考，并成为它的第一个消费者。思考得有点不同，完全说得通，我如何构建代码，以及成为它的第一个消费者……我认为当你构建一个库或 API 或类似的东西时，这真的很明显，就像一个实际发布的 API，但所有软件在某种程度上，当你构建层时，都是下一层的 API，对吧？所以……或者下一层的 API，如果你愿意的话。所以拥有那个反思点，我认为非常有价值。但是，我只是……这很有趣，因为做了这么久，我的意思是，一直到持续集成、持续部署，我挣扎着
My customers are seeing something that I just wrote, which is great. It's fulfilling because I just wrote it and I'm delivering value to the business. But also, if something goes wrong with it, I just wrote it, right? When I have those moments where I write something and I put it in production and something goes wrong or whatever because there's different data, things that I didn't account for, my
我的客户正在使用我刚刚编写的功能，这很棒。这让我很有成就感，因为代码是我写的，我正在为业务创造价值。但同时，如果它出了问题，那也是我写的，对吧？当我写完代码并将其投入生产环境，却因为数据差异或我未考虑到的情况而出现问题时，我的
reaction I find usually under those circumstances is, oh, right, of course. Of course I didn't think of that thing and now I know exactly where to go to fix it. And if I deploy that code six months from now, and someone says, hey, this thing is happening in production, we'll just be like, is that something I did? Is it something someone else did? I don't know. Let's go spend three days sort of trying to figure out where the bug might be. We'll do some git blame for six months and try to figure out where this happened. Yeah, bisect thousands and thousands of commits. Exactly, exactly.
反应通常是：哦，对了，理应如此。我当然没考虑到那一点，现在我知道去哪里修复它了。但如果我在六个月后才部署这段代码，有人说，嘿，生产环境出问题了，我们就会想：这是我做的吗？还是别人做的？我不知道。让我们花三天时间去排查错误可能在哪里。我们会用 git blame 查看六个月前的记录，试图找出问题发生在哪里。没错，去二分查找成千上万次的提交记录。确实如此。
And so I think of testing, one key point behind testing is just pulling that in even more, right? So I'm writing code and I'm not a zealot when it comes to test-driven development. I'm going to write a test for everything. There's absolutely cases where I say, oh, okay, this is,
所以我认为测试的一个关键点就是把反馈周期缩短，对吧？我在写代码时，并不是测试驱动开发的狂热信徒，非要给每样东西都写测试。绝对有些情况下我会说，哦，好吧，这个，
I totally understand what this needs to do. I think it's going to be a little tricky to get it right. I'm going to write a test and then I'm just going to iterate on this thing until I get it right. There are other times where the testing is awkward or weird and it just feels like I'm cementing my idea before I get there. I mean, there's lots of arguments on both sides of that, but either way, the ability to just validate as I'm working that my ideas are correct i think is is one um yeah that makes sense really good reason to test um yeah in a way it's a it's a it's a customer before the customer right so yeah and i would say with that it's a customer in two different ways so
我完全明白它需要做什么。我觉得要把它写对可能有点棘手。我会写一个测试，然后不断迭代，直到把它写对。还有些时候，测试会显得很尴尬或奇怪，感觉就像在还没想清楚之前就把想法固定下来了。关于这一点双方都有很多争论，但无论如何，能够在我工作时验证我的想法是否正确，我认为是一个……嗯，确实很有道理，是一个很好的测试理由。嗯，在某种程度上，它是在客户使用之前的“客户”，对吧？所以我认为它在两个方面充当了客户的角色：
one i'm getting that feedback right away so again it, it's totally fresh. If I write a bug and I catch it immediately, it's not even annoying. It's just like, oh, okay, yeah, that happened. I will fix it and I move on as opposed to again, the day or week or month later. But also you become the first consumer of your API, right? Or your design as you're writing tests for it. So you say, okay, I need to test this thing and here's how I would pass data into it and here's how I would get data out of it. And this feels really clunky. Maybe my design isn't actually that good, right?
第一，我能立即得到反馈，所以一切都是新鲜的。如果我写了一个 bug 并立即发现它，那甚至不会让人烦恼。只会觉得：哦，好吧，确实发生了。我修复它然后继续前进，而不是像之前说的那样，等到一天、一周或一个月后才发现。第二，你在编写测试时，就成了你自己的 API 或设计的第一个使用者，对吧？你会想：好吧，我需要测试这个东西，我该如何传入数据，又该如何获取数据？如果感觉很笨拙，也许我的设计其实并不好，对吧？
Maybe I'll think a little bit differently about how I'm structuring my code and kind of being that first consumer of it. think a little bit differently totally makes sense how i'm structuring my code and the kind of being that first consumer of it um i think that's really evident when you're building a library or an api or something like that like an actual published api but all all software to some degree as you're building up layers is an api to the next layer right so um, or an API for the next layer, if you will. And so having that point of reflection, I think is really valuable. But like, I just, it's interesting, because having done it for so long, I mean, all the way up to continuous integration, continuous deployment, I struggled
也许我会重新思考代码的结构，作为第一个使用者去审视它。这种重新思考代码结构并作为第一个使用者的做法非常有意义。我认为当你构建库、API 或类似发布的 API 时，这一点尤为明显。但实际上，所有软件在构建层级时，在某种程度上都是下一层的 API，或者说是为下一层提供的 API。因此，拥有这种反思的机会是非常有价值的。但我觉得很有趣，因为做了这么久，一直到持续集成和持续部署，我曾经挣扎过
to project myself back into the world where I, you know tests or I didn't have continuous integration, continuous deployment, and even imagine what that was like. Because I was talking to someone recently where we were talking about going, this is a really good example, going back and working on something that I haven't touched in a while. And having the suite of tests that basically says, if I change this in a breaking way, or I break something else by trying to fix whatever it is that I'm trying to fix right now, that'll be really clear, right? If you go back to a code base that doesn't have any tests around it, and you think, okay, now I need to understand every single facet of how this code interacts, so that I know that if i make this change it's going to be safe that's a really uncomfortable situation yeah right yep and so if someone uh if for everyone out there who's had that experience that's how that's how everyone who looks at your code
把自己重新投射回那个我没有测试，或者没有持续集成、持续部署的世界，甚至去想象那是什么样子。因为我最近和某人聊天时谈到，这是一个很好的例子，回到并处理一些我有一段时间没碰过的东西。拥有一套测试套件，它基本上会告诉你，如果我以破坏性的方式修改了它，或者在我试图修复当前正在修复的问题时破坏了其他东西，那将会非常清楚，对吧？如果你回到一个没有任何测试的代码库，你会想，好吧，现在我需要理解这段代码交互的每一个方面，这样我就知道如果我做出这个改变是安全的，那是一个非常不舒服的情况，是的，没错，所以对于每一个有过这种经历的人来说，这就是每一个看你代码的人
sees right right so so so if you come to your code a year later and you have that agoraphobia and you just say oh i'll forget it i just it's done i just need to delete this because i don't know what i'm doing that everyone who comes and visits your github page that's what how they're gonna feel too yeah yeah it's absolutely true like i think we we think of the consumers or the readers of our code often in terms of other people and and forget about us in a week or a month. Like I might be the maintainer of this code, but I have a lot of other things going on, right?
所看到的，对吧，所以如果你一年后回到你的代码，你有那种广场恐惧症，你只是说，哦，算了吧，我只是，它完成了，我只需要删除它，因为我不知道我在做什么，那么每一个访问你的 GitHub 页面的人，他们也会有这种感觉，是的，这绝对是真的，就像我认为我们经常从其他人的角度考虑我们代码的消费者或读者，而忘记了我们自己在一周或一个月后的样子。就像我可能是这段代码的维护者，但我还有很多其他事情要做，对吧？
I'm going to go work on a different project in a different part of the code base and then come back and say, what was it I was trying to do here? I mean, there's lots of outside of tests. There's, you know, naming and structure and good abstractions and clear boundaries and commenting. There's a million other ways to make that better.
我要去处理代码库中不同部分的另一个项目，然后回来问，我在这里想做什么？我的意思是，除了测试之外，还有很多东西。你知道，命名、结构、良好的抽象、清晰的边界和注释。还有一百万种其他方法可以让它变得更好。
Yep. And the tests help with that. I think, you know, maybe your first test can only be, you know, test domain. And it just runs your whole program. And then you find that, okay, I need to wait three hours to know if my test passed or not. Maybe I need to factorize this down. And, oh, now I factorized it down, but now I need a simulated clock because I was using the system clock and it only worked when I ran the whole thing. And so eventually when you're done with that exercise, you'll have much
是的。测试对此有帮助。我想，你知道，也许你的第一个测试只能是，你知道，测试域。它只是运行你的整个程序。然后你发现，好吧，我需要等待三个小时才能知道我的测试是否通过。也许我需要把它分解。而且，哦，现在我把它分解了，但我现在需要一个模拟时钟，因为我使用的是系统时钟，它只有在我运行整个程序时才有效。所以最终当你完成那个练习时，你会有更好的
better quality code. Right. And I think that the small increments, I mean, to your point, coming from the other way, having the units, right? Talking about unit testing as kind of a lowest level um breaking those apart being able to reason about the work they do and then composing them together into higher levels of um whatever output or or uh abstraction higher levels of abstraction is is a very good design practice right and so using tests as a validation that you're doing that effectively i think is is nice um i i use this expression and i think it actually just comes from my manufacturing days i don't know if people actually talk in this way but um so when i was manufacturing we were building
质量的代码。没错。而且我认为小增量，我的意思是，就你的观点而言，从另一个方向来看，拥有单元，对吧？谈论单元测试作为一种最低级别，将它们拆开，能够推理它们所做的工作，然后将它们组合成更高级别的，无论是什么输出或抽象，更高级别的抽象是一种非常好的设计实践，对吧？所以使用测试作为你有效地做到这一点的验证，我认为很好，我使用这个表达，我认为它实际上来自我的制造业时代，我不知道人们是否真的这样说话，但是，所以当我在制造业时，我们正在建造
circuit boards basically and we helped our customers with what we called design for testability and so we would relay out the circuit boards in a way that the probes that came, I mean, we basically had electrical unit testing, right? You could put probes on the board and test a sub circuit of the overall circuit to say it's working effectively. All the solder joints are good, like that sort of thing. Yep. Yep. And you can, it's easy to think about in that physical sense,
电路板，基本上我们帮助我们的客户进行所谓的“可测试性设计”，所以我们会重新布局电路板，以便探针可以，我的意思是，我们基本上进行了电气单元测试，对吧？你可以在板上放置探针并测试整个电路的子电路，以说明它工作有效。所有的焊点都很好，诸如此类的事情。是的。是的。而且很容易在物理意义上思考，
or at least it is for me, because I was there that, you know, you need to be able to fit a probe and you need to be able to break up this part of the circuit in a way that allows you to not have, you know, electrical bleed into other parts and stuff like that. And, and I think that really carries into how we build software. And I think if you design in a way that's more testable, you actually design better software. I mean, there are weird edge cases for sure. But when you think about isolating out business logic from inputs and outputs, right? have, you know, some patterns that talk about this, like ports and adapters or hexagonal architecture, these sorts of things. The core is meant to be pure business logic. And that is a much more testable unit than if the core knows about the database and about the web server and the format of data coming in, right? So if you push serialization and deserialization out to the boundaries and focus the entire core of your application, your system, whatever it is, to business logic, then you can just hand it, you know, manufactured data instead of, OK, I got to write all this stuff into a database and then send this thing over the wire, you know, through the web. And then it becomes this really complex way to
或者至少对我来说是这样，因为我当时在那里，你知道，你需要能够安装一个探针，你需要能够以一种允许你没有，你知道，电流泄漏到其他部分等方式分解电路的这一部分。而且，我认为这确实延续到了我们构建软件的方式中。而且我认为如果你以更可测试的方式设计，你实际上设计出了更好的软件。我的意思是，肯定有一些奇怪的边缘情况。但是当你考虑将业务逻辑与输入和输出隔离开来时，对吧？有一些谈论这个的模式，比如端口和适配器或六边形架构，这些东西。核心应该是纯粹的业务逻辑。而且这是一个比核心知道数据库、Web 服务器和传入数据格式更可测试的单元，对吧？所以如果你把序列化和反序列化推到边界，并将你的应用程序、你的系统，无论它是什么，整个核心集中在业务逻辑上，那么你就可以直接给它，你知道，制造的数据，而不是，好吧，我必须把所有这些东西写进数据库，然后通过网络发送这个东西。然后它就变成了这种非常复杂的方式来
try to build out your tests. And you end up back in that place where you basically run main and check the output at the end and say, I don't know, did I get the right result? Right? Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. I mean, I think, you know, now there's the hot swapping feature. So people are doing web development. And I think that that's the hot swapping feature. So for people doing web development, and I think that that could be a crutch that people could lean on a little too much, say, okay, Firefox is going to be my testing tool, right? And then the issue there is now you're limited by your own time,
尝试构建你的测试。你最终回到了那个地方，你基本上运行 main 并检查最后的输出，然后说，我不知道，我得到正确的结果了吗？对吧？是的。是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我认为，你知道，现在有了热交换功能。所以人们正在进行 Web 开发。而且我认为这是一个热交换功能。所以对于进行 Web 开发的人来说，我认为这可能是一个人们可以稍微多依赖一点的拐杖，说，好吧，Firefox 将成为我的测试工具，对吧？然后这里的问题是现在你受到自己时间的限制，
whereas what you want to do is use the computer's time and and so you could run a thousand tests on the computer and even if they do take a long time you know you could go and do something else um yeah while it's off doing that honestly if you're testing units and functions and stuff like that they will not take a long time computers it turns out are really fast yeah yeah they're very good at doing things in parallel. Computers have a lot going for them that we as humans don't, right? And honestly, it's tedious as a human, right? Especially if I'm a software developer and what I like doing is writing software.
而你想做的是利用计算机的时间，所以你可以在计算机上运行一千个测试，即使它们确实花费很长时间，你知道，你可以去干点别的，嗯，是的，当它在做那个的时候，老实说，如果你在测试单元和函数之类的东西，它们不会花费很长时间，事实证明计算机真的很快，是的，是的，它们非常擅长并行处理。计算机有很多我们人类没有的优势，对吧？而且老实说，作为人类，这很乏味，对吧？特别是如果我是一名软件开发人员，我喜欢做的是编写软件。
Why would I not want to write more software to do the thing that I find really tedious? And just repeatability, right? Like you can say, oh, I'm going to test this case in this case in this case in this case but if you ask me to just say does login work i'm going to put in my username and password i'm going to log in and say yep i logged in therefore it's good but i didn't put the broken password or like the weird spaces or you know the the um disabled user, like all of the conditions that end up being real conditions in your software. It's just hard to reason about those, right?
为什么我不想编写更多的软件来做我发现非常乏味的事情呢？只是可重复性，对吧？就像你可以说，哦，我要测试这个案例，这个案例，这个案例，这个案例，但如果你让我说登录是否有效，我会输入我的用户名和密码，我会登录并说，是的，我登录了，因此它很好，但我没有输入错误的密码，或者像奇怪的空格，或者你知道，嗯，禁用的用户，就像所有最终成为你软件中真实条件的条件一样。很难推理这些，对吧？
And then to go through them all. So for me, it's this repeatability, confidence, all of that and feedback, fast feedback to allow me to just keep going and build the things I'm trying to build. Hey guys, I'm going to interrupt you for a second because we actually have some sponsor information to talk about. We have partnered up with educative.io to talk about an awesome set of classes that
然后把它们全部过一遍。所以对我来说，这就是这种可重复性、信心、所有这些以及反馈，快速反馈让我能够继续前进并构建我试图构建的东西。嘿伙计们，我要打断你们一下，因为我们实际上有一些赞助商信息要谈。我们已经与 educative.io 合作，谈论一套很棒的课程，
they offer for learning all kinds of topics in programming, everything from beginner things to more advanced things like embedded programming. I know, Jason, you looked at some machine learning ones. Yeah, the machine learning course was awesome. They have all sorts of things related to programming, and it's a pretty cool setup. A lot of times you are needing to do your education in a place that may be noisy or loud. And so what Educative has done is they actually, all of their courses are text-based and in interactive notebooks. So you read the material
他们提供学习各种编程主题的课程，从初学者到更高级的主题，如嵌入式编程。我知道，Jason，你看了看一些机器学习的课程。是的，机器学习课程太棒了。他们有各种与编程相关的东西，而且这是一个非常酷的设置。很多时候，你需要在可能嘈杂或吵闹的地方进行教育。所以 Educative 所做的是他们实际上，他们所有的课程都是基于文本的，并且在交互式笔记本中。所以你阅读材料
and you can do it pretty much anywhere because you don't need to put on headphones or anything that would distract you from the rest of your environment. So you're pretty much just reading, but better than a textbook, it's interactive. And so you can actually complete the examples and work on the projects as you're going through. Yeah, if you're like a kinesthetic learner and you're the type of person that needs to sort of do things to really absorb stuff, this is perfect. Because you actually have to go through and run the examples yourself and make changes and improvements. Yeah, I wouldn't have known the word kinesthetic. So thanks to Jason for giving it the technical name, keeping it real here. So yeah, they actually were pointing out
而且你几乎可以在任何地方做，因为你不需要戴耳机或任何会让你分心于环境其余部分的东西。所以你基本上只是在阅读，但比教科书更好，它是交互式的。所以你实际上可以在学习过程中完成示例并处理项目。是的，如果你像一个动觉学习者，并且你是那种需要通过做事情来真正吸收东西的人，这非常完美。因为你实际上必须亲自去运行示例并进行更改和改进。是的，我本来不知道“动觉”这个词。所以感谢 Jason 给它起了个技术名称，在这里保持真实。所以是的，他们实际上指出
that Jason and I are no longer students, unfortunately, but a lot of you guys are. And we've mentioned in the past before the GitHub student developer pack, which is something you can sign up for as a student and includes all sorts of things from a ton of great companies. And Educative is one of those companies. And so if you're a student, check them out through that package. And if you're not, they have actually agreed to give us a discount code for all of our listeners. If you go to educative.io slash programming throwdown, I said that pretty fast, but we have it in the show notes as well. Yep, I'll put it in the notes. Yeah, you can get 20% off of any course. So Jason, so you said you did the machine learning
Jason 和我不再是学生了，不幸的是，但你们中的很多人是。我们过去提到过 GitHub 学生开发者包，这是你可以作为学生注册的东西，包括来自大量优秀公司的各种东西。Educative 就是其中之一。所以如果你是学生，通过那个包看看他们。如果你不是，他们实际上已经同意为我们所有的听众提供折扣代码。如果你去 educative.io 斜杠 programming throwdown，我说得很快，但我们在节目说明中也有它。是的，我会把它放在说明里。是的，你可以获得任何课程 20% 的折扣。所以 Jason，所以你说你做了机器学习
course. Tell us a little bit about what was it like doing that course? Yeah, I thought this was slick. So basically, they kind of walk you through the basics of doing some data science, handling some data frames, and they walk you through training a model. Again, the part I really love is the interactive part. So if you've ever seen Mathematica Notebook, we have Steve Wolfram on the show, so hopefully some of you folks checked that out. Or if you've ever played with iPython Notebook or Jupyter or any of these technologies, you kind of know what it's like to kind of get that instant feedback. It's actually really gratifying. And this is similar where it shows some formula.
课程。告诉我们做那个课程是什么感觉？是的，我觉得这很顺滑。所以基本上，他们引导你了解做一些数据科学、处理一些数据帧的基础知识，他们引导你训练一个模型。同样，我真正喜欢的部分是交互式部分。所以如果你曾经见过 Mathematica Notebook，我们在节目中有 Steve Wolfram，所以希望你们中的一些人看了那个。或者如果你曾经玩过 iPython Notebook 或 Jupyter 或任何这些技术，你有点知道获得那种即时反馈是什么感觉。这实际上非常令人满足。这很相似，它显示了一些公式。
You can go in and tweak it. You can see sort of how you can break it, how you can make it better. And it kind of gets you in that sort of test, retest kind of mindset, which is super exciting. They also have a set of from scratch courses that i briefly looked at and these are awesome they basically take you from almost zero knowledge all the way to you know kind of writing your first programs and being a developer right so i mean i remember when i started um you know when i was in grade school. And without knowing basic things like LS, right? Or find or just things like that,
你可以进去调整它。你可以看到你如何破坏它，如何让它变得更好。它让你进入那种测试、重测的心态，这非常令人兴奋。他们还有一套我简要看过的从零开始的课程，这些课程太棒了，它们基本上带你从几乎零知识一直到，你知道，编写你的第一个程序并成为一名开发人员，对吧？所以我的意思是，我记得我开始的时候，嗯，你知道，我在小学的时候。而且不知道像 LS 这样的基本东西，对吧？或者查找，或者只是像那样的东西，
it's actually really hard to get started. You start saying, okay, I have these two files. I need to merge them. Let me write a C program, right? And so what this does, it kind of walks you through. It says, okay, let's wipe this light clean and start from scratch. Here's a list
实际上很难开始。你开始说，好吧，我有这两个文件。我需要合并它们。让我写一个 C 程序，对吧？所以这就是它所做的，它引导你。它说，好吧，让我们把这个擦干净，从头开始。这是一个列表
of kind of really good utilities and it gets you up to speed really quickly yeah they have a variety of languages javascript java c++ rust scala they're kind of all over the place and covering a wide variety of things so it's not just limited to a lot of the tutorials today seem to be python and i know jason's a big python guy i'm not so uh it always feels a little bit the tutorials today seem to be Python. And I know Jason's a big Python guy. I'm not. So it always feels a little bit sad when I go to click on some interesting programming topic, and they're kind of doing it in Python, just because sometimes it's a little hard for me, at least to kind of apply that to the work that I do. And I, you know, once you kind of are well established and know something, you can poke around at internet tutorials and pick up a gem or two. But having a curated course that goes, you know, through a sort of well
各种非常好的实用程序，它让你很快上手，是的，他们有各种各样的语言，JavaScript、Java、C++、Rust、Scala，它们几乎无处不在，涵盖了各种各样的事情，所以它不仅限于很多今天的教程似乎是 Python，我知道 Jason 是个大 Python 迷，我不是，所以它总是感觉有点，今天的教程似乎是 Python。我知道 Jason 是个大 Python 迷。我不是。所以当我点击一些有趣的编程主题时，它总是感觉有点悲伤，他们有点用 Python 做它，只是因为有时对我来说，至少很难将其应用到我所做的工作中。而且我，你知道，一旦你相当成熟并了解某事，你就可以在互联网教程中四处看看，捡起一两颗宝石。但是有一个精心策划的课程，它经过，你知道，一种很好
thought through syllabus and teaches you stuff in an order that makes sense is enormously helpful for actually learning the material and not just pretending like you're learning the material. And so I really appreciate that about being able to have actual courses. Yeah, totally. So the URL one more time is educative.io slash programming throwdown. It's case insensitive. You can type it however you like it. We'll also give a link in the show notes that you can check out. All right.
思考过的教学大纲，并以有意义的顺序教你东西，这对真正学习材料而不是假装你在学习材料非常有帮助。所以我真的很欣赏能够拥有实际课程这一点。是的，完全正确。所以 URL 再说一次是 educative.io 斜杠 programming throwdown。它不区分大小写。你可以随心所欲地输入它。我们还会在节目说明中提供一个链接，你可以查看。好的。
Well, I think it's time to go back to the interview. Thank you to Educative sponsor for today's episode. So what is the point then of continuous integration? What, you know, someone might say, well, I can just run my tests before I get push. Yeah, so I think it's easier to reason about continuous integration as you think about larger and larger teams, because it really is that point of integration. Right. And so I know for some of your audience, probably working in a large team on of the code base or maybe change a piece of code, a class, a function, whatever that they don't realize is being used somewhere else.
好吧，我想是时候回到采访了。感谢今天这一集的赞助商 Educative。那么持续集成的意义何在呢？什么，你知道，有人可能会说，好吧，我可以在 git push 之前运行我的测试。是的，所以我认为在考虑越来越大的团队时，更容易推理持续集成，因为它确实是集成的那个点。没错。所以我知道对于你们的一些听众来说，可能在一个大型团队中工作，或者可能更改了一段代码、一个类、一个函数，无论他们没有意识到在其他地方被使用的东西。
And so learning about those conflicts after long periods of work, and it's interesting, our definitions of long periods of work have changed over the time that I've been in software, but I've seen projects where entirely different teams fork something, work on it for six months, and then try to merge their changes back together. I mean, there goes another six months. Yeah, that's right. And so merging them together, you know, daily, less than daily, just saying, oh, okay, we made this change, let's merge it in, gives you the opportunity to identify any conflicts as they start to arise. They usually tend to be quite small. But what you're doing is effectively taking those two sets of changes, bringing them together, which is a system or is a view of the code base that neither of those individuals had, right? Bringing those two sets of changes together and then running the set of tests
所以在大工作量之后了解这些冲突，这很有趣，我们对大工作量的定义在我从事软件工作的这段时间里发生了变化，但我见过一些项目，完全不同的团队分叉了一些东西，工作了六个月，然后试图将他们的更改合并在一起。我的意思是，又过去了六个月。是的，没错。所以每天，少于每天地将它们合并在一起，只是说，哦，好吧，我们做了这个改变，让我们合并它，让你有机会在冲突开始出现时识别它们。它们通常往往很小。但你实际上是在做的是获取这两组更改，将它们放在一起，这是一个系统，或者是一个代码库的视图，这两个人都没有，对吧？将这两组更改放在一起，然后运行一组测试
on that right and then assuming that all works you know or i guess whatever it's happening on branches but then giving you the opportunity to bring them together um and then you know continuing to build on that right so people are taking making small changes to the code base uh and bringing them together and then that in git probably master but your default branch whatever it might be called trunk um is constantly in a state where you know it to be good right in an ideal world you get to what we would call continuous delivery which is i always have a known good code base, right? I haven't made changes that will cause problems. And so at any given time, I could deploy it, right? So continuous delivery,
在那上面，对吧，然后假设所有这些都有效，你知道，或者我猜在分支上发生的任何事情，但随后给你机会将它们放在一起，嗯，然后你知道，继续在那上面构建，对吧？所以人们正在对代码库进行小的更改，并将它们放在一起，然后那个在 git 中可能是 master，但你的默认分支无论它可能叫什么，主干，总是处于一种你知道它是好的状态，对吧？在理想的世界中，你达到了我们所谓的持续交付，即我总是有一个已知的好代码库，对吧？我没有做出会导致问题的更改。所以随时，我可以部署它，对吧？所以持续交付，
you might be adding the packaging, right? Maybe I take that merge together code and build in today's world, probably a Docker image or something that would be the thing that i'm going to deploy or a jar file or a gem or whatever i'm working yeah um and and then what we do is internally and many of our customers do with our product is continuous deployment which is okay i have a known good asset or artifact why is it not in production already i mean it's got new capability. Let's put it in a production environment and have users have access to that, right? Yeah, that makes sense. Can you do like, I guess you could do like a nine to five continuous deployment and then turn it off on the weekend or something like that.
你可能正在添加打包，对吧？也许我获取那个合并在一起的代码并构建在今天的世界中，可能是一个 Docker 镜像或类似的东西，这将是我要部署的东西，或者一个 jar 文件或一个 gem 或任何我正在工作的东西，是的，嗯，然后我们内部所做的是，我们的许多客户使用我们的产品进行持续部署，即好吧，我有一个已知的好资产或工件，为什么它还没有在生产中？我的意思是它有新的功能。让我们把它放在生产环境中，让用户可以访问它，对吧？是的，这很有道理。你可以做，我想你可以做九到五的持续部署，然后在周末关掉它之类的。
Yeah, it's an interesting question. I mean, we don't do that um we actually i mean our team is globally distributed so that's true yeah so we work much more than than those hours uh just because of where we are um but uh i think ultimately with like my history with continuous deployment the first time when we started this marketplace in 2011, we talked about doing it. And I was like, that sounds crazy. Deploying is always a disaster. Why would I want to do more of that? But really, it's about deploying. Deploying is a problem because you have three months worth of changes or two weeks worth of changes, whatever that might be. And so there's a lot of risk.
是的，这是一个有趣的问题。我的意思是，我们不那样做，嗯，我们实际上，我的意思是我们的团队是全球分布的，所以那是真的，是的，所以我们工作的时间比那些时间多得多，只是因为我们在哪里，嗯，但是，嗯，我认为最终关于我使用持续部署的历史，2011 年我们开始这个市场时，我们谈到了这样做。我当时想，这听起来很疯狂。部署总是一场灾难。我为什么要多做那个？但实际上，它是关于部署的。部署是一个问题，因为你有三个月的更改或两周的更改，无论那可能是什么。所以有很多风险。
There's a lot of change and change is risk in your software environment. Ideally, you've done a great job with your testing and continuous integration. But now I'm pushing that out. I don't know which change caused the problem. But as you break those chunks down smaller and smaller, the risk is getting broken down into smaller and smaller bits. Right. So absolutely one, you know, one line of code could take down your entire production site. But if you push a one line change and production goes down,
有很多变化，变化是你软件环境中的风险。理想情况下，你在测试和持续集成方面做得很好。但现在我正在推动它。我不知道是哪个更改导致了问题。但当你把这些块拆分得越来越小时，风险正在被拆分成越来越小的位。没错。所以绝对，你知道，一行代码可能会导致你的整个生产站点瘫痪。但如果你推动一个一行的更改，而生产瘫痪了，
you're not going to spend a lot of time thinking about what the cause was, right? You're just going to push the next one. You're going to fix it and repush it or you're going to roll it back and you're done. So you get to this state where basically we don't even think about deploying it's just
你不会花很多时间去思考原因是什么，对吧？你只会推动下一个。你会修复它并重新推动它，或者你会回滚它，你就完成了。所以你达到了这种状态，基本上我们甚至不考虑部署，它只是
happening right and people are moving on to other things and so the the kind of fear or stress of the deployment has gone away yeah that's a that's a really good point there's this other part of this too which is uh i don't remember where i read this but but um i think it was in some game development blog but basically if let's say there's an issue with your login page, and that's one of 100 bugs that you have. Even if people can get past the login page, it's just my inconvenience. If you give this to a group of people,
发生了，对吧，人们正在转向其他事情，所以部署的恐惧或压力已经消失了，是的，这是一个非常好的观点，这还有另一部分，即，嗯，我不记得我在哪里读到这个了，但是，嗯，我想是在某个游戏开发博客中，但基本上，如果假设你的登录页面有问题，而那是你拥有的 100 个错误之一。即使人们可以越过登录页面，那也只是我的不便。如果你把这个给一群人，
whether it's testers or your final audience, 99.9% of them will report that bug on the login page they'll say oh yeah i couldn't have an email address with an underscore in it or whatever it is and none of those people that find that bug will report the next bug because they just feel like oh i'm done you know i did my due diligence now there's two three four bugs whatever i'll just i'll either live with it or i'll move on and so you only ever get the login bugs there's this huge perception bias and so as you said you get it smaller and smaller you'll catch you'll catch more and more things yeah that's really interesting i mean i think that the other thing that that speaks to for me is i do believe you know even with great continuous
无论是测试人员还是你的最终受众，99.9% 的人都会报告登录页面上的那个错误，他们会说，哦，是的，我不能有一个带有下划线的电子邮件地址，或者无论它是什么，并且那些发现该错误的人中没有一个会报告下一个错误，因为他们只是觉得，哦，我完成了，你知道，我尽了我的勤勉，现在有两个、三个、四个错误，无论是什么，我要么忍受它，要么我会继续前进，所以你只会得到登录错误，存在这种巨大的感知偏差，所以正如你所说，你把它变得越来越小，你会捕捉到越来越多的东西，是的，这真的很有趣，我的意思是，我认为这对我来说说明的另一件事是，我确实相信，你知道，即使有伟大的持续
integration um with with strong test automation automation and good coverage and all these things, there's no eliminating risk. So ultimately, you will ship bugs into production. That will happen. It's like everybody makes mistakes. It's a thing. Every intern does it at least once. That's right. That's right.
集成，嗯，有强大的测试自动化和良好的覆盖率以及所有这些东西，没有消除风险。所以最终，你会将错误发布到生产中。那会发生的。就像每个人都会犯错。这是一件事。每个实习生至少做一次。那是真的。那是真的。
Probably more. Yeah. does it at least once that's right that's right probably more um and and so then you know you can't be relying on your users though to report all of the issues that they find right and especially if they're they say well i reported bugs before this is annoying so um having really great uh visibility into what's happening in your production environment. We use something called Rollbar. There's others like it, which is an unhandled exception service, I guess, basically. So when an exception is thrown in our code, something unexpected happens and we aren't catching it, right? Meaning no developer thought, oh, this is a condition that can occur and we know what to do.
可能更多。是的。至少做一次，那是真的，那是真的，可能更多，嗯，然后你知道，你不能依赖你的用户来报告他们发现的所有问题，对吧，特别是如果他们说，好吧，我以前报告过错误，这很烦人，所以，对你的生产环境中发生的事情有非常好的可见性。我们使用一种叫做 Rollbar 的东西。还有其他类似的东西，这是一种未处理的异常服务，我想，基本上。所以当我们的代码中抛出异常时，发生了意想不到的事情，我们没有捕获它，对吧？意味着没有开发人员认为，哦，这是一个可能发生的条件，我们知道该怎么做。
Then it reaches a top level gets posted to another service we get notified and then we can say oh it's like a user is seeing a 500 error or whatever on our site because and then we can trace back here's the stack trace here are the like here are the parameters that were being passed at the time this is the user or this is the organization they're in, or whatever kind of information we might have, right, right, in order to immediately say, oh, there's been a spike in this kind of error, or this is a new error, something must have gone wrong. And we can go track that down without, without the user having to do anything. Right. And then we apply that to, you know, metrics that seem out of line, like this rate has spiked for whatever reason, or we're seeing this new log line that we've never seen before.
然后它到达顶层，被发布到另一个服务，我们得到通知，然后我们可以说，哦，就像用户在我们的网站上看到 500 错误或什么东西，因为，然后我们可以追溯，这是堆栈跟踪，这些是，比如这些是当时传递的参数，这是用户或他们所在的组织，或者我们可能拥有的任何类型的信息，对吧，对吧，为了立即说，哦，这种错误出现了峰值，或者这是一个新错误，一定出了什么问题。我们可以去追踪它，而无需用户做任何事情。没错。然后我们将它应用到，你知道，看起来不正常的指标，比如这个速率因为某种原因飙升，或者我们看到了我们以前从未见过的这个新日志行。
You know, what's up with that? And having that kind of visibility or observability on your platform is super valuable because of that effect like expecting that users are going to report issues that they see is just it's great if they do but it's not going to happen for everything you know to your point that happens in production yeah it totally makes sense yeah so um yeah i think i think um another really nice thing about CI that's integrated with things like GitHub is that you can guarantee that the person who wants to merge in this code has run all the tests. So, I mean, you see this all the time with people who don't have CI set up where um someone says hey i have this pull request that adds this new feature uh the the i've done i've made this mistake myself i mean i say sure the feature sounds pretty cool and then the next version doesn't work and and i'm totally not
你知道，那怎么了？并且在你的平台上拥有那种可见性或可观测性是非常有价值的，因为那种效果，就像期望用户会报告他们看到的问题，如果他们这样做很好，但它不会发生在所有事情上，你知道，就你的观点而言，那发生在生产中，是的，这完全有道理，是的，所以，嗯，是的，我想，我想，嗯，CI 的另一个非常好的地方是它与 GitHub 之类的东西集成，你可以保证想要合并此代码的人已经运行了所有测试。所以，我的意思是，你经常看到那些没有设置 CI 的人，嗯，有人说嘿，我有这个拉取请求，添加了这个新功能，嗯，我，我自己犯了这个错误，我的意思是，我说当然，这个功能听起来很酷，然后下一个版本不起作用，而且我完全没有
expecting that because it was contributed code that that uh that that you know i didn't have in my mental model and ci kind of inoculates you from that right exactly so so there's an expectation you know when you when you put up the pr i mean first of all there's a check that basically says this can't be merged because we you know circle ci or your ci platform hasn't returned a positive status on that right so you can depending on the tools you use you can make these sort of things mandatory like it's impossible to merge uh a pr that doesn't have a set of tests that have passed uh like the whole sorry the whole test suite having passed not just the ones that were
预料到这一点，因为它是贡献的代码，嗯，那，你知道，我没有在我的心理模型中，而 CI 某种程度上为你接种了疫苗，对吧，完全正确，所以，所以有一个期望，你知道，当你提出 PR 时，我的意思是首先有一个检查，基本上说这不能合并，因为我们，你知道，Circle CI 或你的 CI 平台没有返回积极的状态，对吧，所以你可以根据你使用的工具，你可以使这些事情成为强制性的，就像不可能合并一个没有通过一组测试的 PR，就像整个，抱歉，整个测试套件已经通过，不仅仅是那些
associated with that the other um we can um you know plug in things like code coverage to that and say if the coverage has gone down significantly we actually have gone back and forth on that because code coverage is it's it's a whole other topic yeah i mean it's very context sensitive right i mean if you're writing a device driver or something might be very difficult yeah yeah yeah and then you can get these minor little oddities that change it to be down and then you know you can't merge but really you just added some whatever yeah yeah um but those sorts of things to really say okay now and and getting to the role of the code reviewer which is a bit different in every organization but being able to get the code reviewer to a place
与此相关的，其他的，嗯，我们可以，嗯，你知道，插入像代码覆盖率之类的东西，并说如果覆盖率显著下降，我们实际上已经来回讨论过这个问题，因为代码覆盖率，它是另一个话题，是的，我的意思是它非常依赖上下文，对吧，我的意思是如果你正在编写设备驱动程序或类似的东西，可能非常困难，是的，是的，然后你可以得到这些微小的奇怪之处，改变它以至于下降，然后你知道，你不能合并，但实际上你只是添加了一些无论什么，是的，是的，嗯，但那些事情确实说，好吧，现在，并且进入代码审查员的角色，这在每个组织中都有点不同，但能够让代码审查员到达一个地方
where they're really looking for you know large-scale intent do i understand what you've done and therefore this feels like something that will be good for us if you're going back to future me and future other people, you know, is it maintainable? Does it seem like there are tests that execute the kinds of conditions that I think need to be executed to really, you know, validate what you've done? And really be thinking high level versus, I mean, as a code reviewer, if I'm expected to figure out if the logic is all correct, meaning like I'm going to read through and parse all of the context that you had in your head or try to reverse engineer what you had in your head and establish with the following set of inputs, will I get the outputs I expected? That's a really hard job to ask a
他们真的在寻找，你知道，大规模的意图，我理解你做了什么吗，因此这感觉像是对我们有好处的事情，如果你要回到未来的我和未来的其他人，你知道，它是可维护的吗？看起来是否有测试执行了我认为需要执行的条件，以真正，你知道，验证你所做的事情？并且真正进行高层思考，而不是，我的意思是，作为代码审查员，如果我被期望弄清楚逻辑是否完全正确，意味着我将通读并解析你脑子里的所有上下文，或者尝试逆向工程你脑子里的东西，并确定以下一组输入，我会得到我预期的输出吗？这是一个非常困难的工作，要求一个
code reviewer to do. As a reviewer, I want to look at your tests, going back to why you would have tests, and say, these tests make sense as testing the input. And since you've obviously run them, then I know the output is correct given these inputs. So I have confidence in the correctness of your code. And now I'm looking at, is this long-term maintainable does it structurally make sense is it in the right place in the code base does this feature make sense or does it feel like the right implementation of the product requirement those sorts of things that is where a human's intelligence can be more more useful yeah yeah totally makes sense so um okay cool so So, okay, cool. So I think we've motivated continuous integration for folks out there. Just one thing, continuous integration doesn't have to be for big teams or anything like that.
代码审查员去做。作为审查员，我想看看你的测试，回到为什么你会进行测试，并说，这些测试作为测试输入是有意义的。而且因为你显然已经运行了它们，所以我知道在这些输入下输出是正确的。所以我对你的代码的正确性有信心。现在我正在看，这是否是长期可维护的，它在结构上是否有意义，它在代码库中的位置是否正确，这个功能是否有意义，或者它是否感觉像是产品需求的正确实现，诸如此类的事情，这就是人类的智慧可以更有用，是的，是的，完全有道理，所以，嗯，好的，酷，所以，好的，酷。所以我认为我们已经为那里的朋友们激发了持续集成。只有一件事，持续集成不必针对大型团队或类似的东西。
If you look at over the past, like over the shows, I've pointed people every now and then to projects I've worked on. All of them have CircleCI integration. And some of them i worked on by myself they didn't really turn out to anything but that's always kind of where you start is with that so that you can go back and um remember remember future you is basically a different person and so you're always going to have multiple um perspectives on anything write, even if you're doing it by yourself. Yeah, absolutely. And I think earlier I was talking about larger teams just to give the context of how did this come to be. But it's funny.
如果你看看过去，比如在节目中，我时不时地向人们指出我参与过的项目。它们都有 CircleCI 集成。而且有些是我自己做的，它们并没有真正变成什么，但那总是你开始的地方，这样你就可以回去，嗯，记住，记住未来的你基本上是另一个人，所以你总是会对任何事情有多种视角，对吧，即使你是自己做的。是的，绝对。而且我想早些时候我谈论大型团队只是为了提供这是如何产生的背景。但这很有趣。
I mentioned sort of not being able to imagine a world without it. And similarly, you know, the first thing I do when I sit down to write something is like, OK, what's my testing strategy? Even for this silly little pet project or whatever, what's my testing strategy going to be? You know, what tools are available to me, depending on the language or whatever? And then how am I going to attach CI to this? Yeah. And great thing i think you were saying this before we jumped on but um you know with circle ci or others like us you can get some some free build capacity for your small hobby projects and things
我提到了某种无法想象没有它的世界。同样，你知道，我坐下来写东西时做的第一件事就是，好吧，我的测试策略是什么？即使是这个愚蠢的小宠物项目或无论什么，我的测试策略将是什么？你知道，根据语言或无论什么，我可以使用什么工具？然后我将如何将 CI 附加到这个上面？是的，我认为你在我们跳上去之前就在说这个，嗯，你知道，使用 Circle CI 或像我们这样的其他人，你可以为你的小型爱好项目和事情获得一些免费的构建容量
like that so this stuff is easy to come by uh you know in our case you don't have to do anything you basically click a button add your project you're good to go um and and then it's yeah it's great you come back in six months and say oh oh, yeah, I wanted to add this tweak or this capability. And you can jump right back in, do a little bit of work and know that you didn't break something while you were in there because, you know, you didn't have to load the whole thing back up into your head. You have that confidence with it. So, yeah, now I kind of never do anything without without that yeah same here and you know the thing too is i've gotten better at writing tests when i started out i had this you know when i started my career i had this misconception that when you wrote the tests
像那样，所以这些东西很容易得到，嗯，你知道在我们的例子中，你不需要做任何事情，你基本上点击一个按钮，添加你的项目，你就准备好了，嗯，然后它，是的，这很棒，你六个月后回来，说，哦，哦，是的，我想添加这个调整或这个功能。你可以直接跳回来，做一点工作，并知道你在那里时没有破坏什么，因为，你知道，你不必把整个东西重新加载到你的脑子里。你对它有那种信心。所以，是的，现在我几乎从来不做任何没有那个的事情，是的，我也是，你知道，事情也是，我已经在编写测试方面变得更好了，当我开始时，我有这个，你知道，当我开始我的职业生涯时，我有这个误解，即当你编写测试时
more often than not you would that bugs were because of some flawed assumption and when you wrote the test you'd write it with the flawed assumption and you would give yourself a green light. And I'm not saying that doesn't happen, but as you get better at writing tests, that happens very rarely. So for example, let's say you're writing a sort function.
通常情况下，你会，错误是因为一些错误的假设，当你编写测试时，你会带着错误的假设编写它，你会给自己一个绿灯。我并不是说这不会发生，但随着你编写测试变得更好，这种情况很少发生。所以例如，假设你正在编写一个排序函数。
So you're expecting data to be distributed in a certain way where you want to write your own sort function that's going to be better than the generic sort, right? So, you know, in your test, if you have some numbers and then you know what they are sorted and you make that your test, yeah, you can maybe fall into this trap, right? Or maybe you didn't think about three-digit numbers, like your whole trick was that it was on two digit. Right. But but another way to write this test would be to just generate oodles of numbers, sort them with your sort, sort them with some other sort, whatever is built into C++ or whatever it is, and then make sure they're the same. And you can do that 10,000 times. And if you write a test in that way, you're much more likely to catch even a flawed assumption. And so it turns out as you get better writing tests, you've more often than not,
所以你期望数据以某种方式分布，你想编写自己的排序函数，它将比通用排序更好，对吧？所以，你知道，在你的测试中，如果你有一些数字，然后你知道它们是什么排序的，你把这作为你的测试，是的，你可能陷入这个陷阱，对吧？或者也许你没有考虑三位数，就像你的整个技巧是它是两位数。对吧。但是，但是编写此测试的另一种方法是只生成大量的数字，用你的排序对它们进行排序，用其他排序对它们进行排序，无论内置在 C++ 中还是无论它是什么，然后确保它们是相同的。你可以做 10,000 次。如果你以这种方式编写测试，你更有可能捕捉到即使是错误的假设。所以事实证明，随着你编写测试变得更好，你更有可能，
now when I write a test, it breaks. You know, the first time I run it. Yeah, that totally makes sense. I mean, I think that there's some trivial things we do where honestly, you just get good at saying this is trivial. I'm calling one function. Yeah. And that function is a system library. I'm just going to assume that it's going to give me the right result. Right.
现在当我编写测试时，它会中断。你知道，我第一次运行它时。是的，这完全有道理。我的意思是，我认为我们做的一些琐碎的事情，老实说，你只是擅长说这是琐碎的。我正在调用一个函数。是的。而且那个函数是一个系统库。我只是假设它会给我正确的结果。对吧。
Yeah. And I think you kind of get stuck writing a bunch of those. And then you think, oh, my gosh, it's so painful. So like everything, there's an ROI question. Right. And if I'm trying to start adding tests, I'm going to say, what's the most critical piece of functionality where the code changes regularly, and I'm going to start building up tests around that, right? Or I have to go refactor this thing, or there's a bug here. That's a big place. Because if there's a bug, it's obviously not tested, right? So I write the test that demonstrates the bug.
是的。而且我认为你有点陷入编写一堆那些东西。然后你认为，哦，天哪，这太痛苦了。所以像所有事情一样，有一个投资回报率问题。对吧。如果我试图开始添加测试，我会说，代码定期更改的最关键功能是什么，我将开始围绕它构建测试，对吧？或者我必须去重构这个东西，或者这里有一个错误。这是一个很大的地方。因为如果有一个错误，它显然没有经过测试，对吧？所以我编写证明错误的测试。
This is the place that I most commonly do effectively test-driven development. I write a test that demonstrates the bug and proves that it's there and then fix it. And if it doesn't fix the test, then I didn't fix the bug, right? So it's a great way to take on those. And if there's a bug, then obviously that logic was harder to reason about, right? Or someone just made a typo or something but i mean it got out so put that test in there and now that you will never have aggression on that bug because now it won't pass the test right yeah so um yeah and there's some interesting just what you were talking about there reminded me of a couple things one some some investment has been made in generative
这是我最常有效地进行测试驱动开发的地方。我编写一个证明错误的测试，并证明它在那里，然后修复它。如果它没有修复测试，那么我没有修复错误，对吧？所以这是一个承担这些的好方法。而且如果有一个错误，那么显然那个逻辑更难推理，对吧？或者有人只是打错了字或什么东西，但我的意思是它出去了，所以把那个测试放在那里，现在你永远不会对那个错误有回归，因为现在它不会通过测试，对吧，是的，所以，嗯，是的，而且有一些有趣的，你刚才在那里谈论的事情让我想起了几件事，一是一些投资已经投入到生成式中
testing uh some some frameworks have this where you can just say, these are my inputs. And sort of this is the transformation that I would expect for the output or whatever. And have those inputs just be generated randomly. I have a mixed relationship or mixed feelings about that because I want my testing to be deterministic. Yeah, that makes sense. So what I will do is if it generates specific cases that fail, I will memorialize those in actual, like, always run this test, right? Always run these inputs. And then maybe at the end say, and generate some random stuff,
测试，呃，有些框架有这种功能，你可以直接说，这些是我的输入。然后这就是我期望得到的输出转换之类的。让这些输入随机生成。我对这种方式有种复杂的关系或复杂的情绪，因为我希望我的测试是确定性的。是的，这很有道理。所以我通常的做法是，如果它生成了导致失败的特定用例，我会把它们记录下来，变成实际的、总是运行的测试，对吧？总是运行这些输入。然后最后可能再说，再生成一些随机的东西，
and we'll see if that finds anything else. But again, if I find those, like, I would hate for it to pass the next time because those particular values didn't get generated right that doesn't feel right to me yeah um yeah we had this issue with with you know i do a bunch of machine learning work and in the beginning we didn't set the random seed and the theory behind that was it should it should be robust you know it should work with any random seed um and that was sort of our our um it's almost like became like a principle thing like hey if it if it didn't pass all the time then we need to work on it and it was just we just gave up we should forget it because because you know it's just so hard to write something when you're dealing in the realm of sort of statistics to that that works a hundred percent of the time and if it
看看能不能发现其他问题。但同样，如果我发现了这些问题，我可不希望下次它通过了，仅仅是因为那些特定的值没有被生成出来，这让我感觉不对劲。是的，嗯，我们在机器学习工作中也遇到过这个问题，起初我们没有设置随机种子，背后的理论是它应该是稳健的，你知道，它应该在任何随机种子下都能工作。这几乎成了一种原则，就像是说，如果它不能一直通过，那我们就需要改进它。但后来我们放弃了，因为当你处理统计学领域的问题时，要写出百分之百能运行的代码实在太难了，如果它
doesn't if you're doing good ci and it only works even 99.9 of the time your ci will will still yell at you and so we finally said no forget it let's fix the random seed and then we can run the test maybe a hundred times in parallel right right yeah huh that, that's actually really interesting. So the other thing that I was thinking about there, when you're talking about running your sort function and running it against the original, is you can actually apply that less so in testing, but to larger scale system design and it's a it's a really cool pattern that that i we've deployed in a couple places and i've seen other people deploy but um where you're you're trying to replace a system and so you slowly run things through both right and make sure and and i guess this happens at very small levels in things like um in like just in time compilers and stuff like that where you compare two different compile paths and make sure that you got the right result um but uh being able to run
不能，而且如果你在做良好的持续集成（CI），即使它有99.9%的时间能运行，你的CI系统还是会向你报错。所以我们最终决定，算了，固定随机种子，这样我们就可以并行运行测试一百次，对吧？对，没错。嗯，这确实非常有趣。所以我想到的另一件事是，当你谈论运行你的排序函数并将其与原始函数进行对比时，你实际上可以将其应用到更大规模的系统设计中，而不仅仅是测试。这是一个非常酷的模式，我在几个地方部署过，也见过其他人部署。当你试图替换一个系统时，你会慢慢地让数据同时通过两个系统，确保……我想这在即时编译器（JIT）之类的小规模层面也会发生，你会比较两个不同的编译路径，确保得到正确的结果。但是，能够运行
totally different systems uh and then say okay do i consistently get the result that i got in the old system now i feel like this one is is for primetime, right? Like we've deployed things in production that were just either big enough, complex enough, important enough in terms of the business that we would run them in the background and just look at the output and, you know, not tell customers that we were running because it didn't matter to them. And then say, okay, yeah, we're consistently getting the same value out of this new system. So maybe it's like faster or a different type of deployment, whatever it might be. But now we have real production level confidence that all the bizarre combinations and permutations
完全不同的系统，然后说，好的，我是否能持续得到我在旧系统中得到的结果？现在我觉得这个系统可以投入生产环境了，对吧？我们已经在生产环境中部署过一些系统，它们要么足够大、足够复杂，要么对业务足够重要，以至于我们会在后台运行它们，只观察输出，而且，你知道，不告诉客户我们在运行，因为这对他们来说没关系。然后说，好的，是的，我们从这个新系统中持续得到了相同的值。所以也许它更快，或者是一种不同的部署方式，无论是什么。但现在我们有了真正的生产级信心，确信我们每天看到的那些奇奇怪怪的组合和排列
that we see every day are going to turn out right because we've run it against the known good version. Yeah yeah that makes sense it totally makes sense so so okay so for folks out there who you know it's okay running tests on your machine seems relatively straightforward so let's say you um you're doing something in python you've already installed python you've installed a whole bunch of dependencies for python and so that that system that's running your code can also run the test it seems pretty reasonable once you go to the cloud i think that's where i think a lot of folks will get lost like like how do i get that machine out there or maybe thousands of machines out there to have this same setup as as my desktop so that i can run the same
都会得到正确的结果，因为我们已经用已知的正确版本运行过它了。是的，这完全说得通。所以，对于那些觉得在自己机器上运行测试似乎相对简单的人来说，假设你在用Python做一些事情，你已经安装了Python，安装了一大堆Python依赖项，那么运行你代码的系统也可以运行测试，这看起来很合理。一旦你到了云端，我想这就是很多人会迷失的地方，比如，我该如何让那台机器，或者可能是成千上万台机器，拥有和我桌面环境一样的配置，以便我能运行同样的
tests like how does how does circle ci kind of work at a high level for folks who've never used it yeah well there's there's actually a really great um sidebar in there around using ci in general uh which is the you know eliminating effectively the, I don't know, worked on my machine bug, right? Because you're not deploying your laptop into production. So it is like your environment needs to be able to be replicated with exactly the right dependencies and all the right versions in order to be able to support the application as you built it and tested it right so ci in addition to validating your code validates that you've
测试？对于那些从未使用过的人来说，Circle CI在高层面上是如何工作的？是的，其实这里有一个非常棒的侧重点，关于在一般情况下使用CI，那就是，有效地消除“在我的机器上能运行”的错误，对吧？因为你不会把你的笔记本电脑部署到生产环境中。所以你的环境需要能够被精确地复制，包括正确的依赖项和所有正确的版本，以便能够支持你构建和测试的应用程序。所以CI除了验证你的代码，还验证了你是否
effectively uh established that memorialize that whatever word you want to use and so if you look at many frameworks like you mentioned python um i'm trying to it depends on which package management system you use but there's requirements.txt, right, which basically lists versions and you can capture and fix the versions that you have in your environment. And so what you would do is spin up a CI environment. I'll go into the details of that in one second. Spin up a CI environment and say, you know um pip install or whatever it is yeah that's right from from requirements.txt and you'll replicate that exact environment right so um in order to speed that up we do things like allowing you to cache your dependencies once you've created that
有效地建立了、记录了——无论你想用什么词——总之，如果你看看许多框架，比如你提到的Python，我正在尝试……这取决于你使用哪种包管理系统，但有requirements.txt，对吧？它基本上列出了版本，你可以捕获并固定你环境中的版本。所以你会做的是启动一个CI环境。我一会儿会详细介绍。启动一个CI环境，然后说，你知道，pip install或者其他什么，从requirements.txt安装，你就会复制那个精确的环境。所以，为了加快速度，我们会做一些事情，比如允许你在创建依赖项后缓存它们，
uh so you can load them back in instead of, because dependency resolution takes some time. You're doing it in every instance of every build that's being run, then you just, you burn a lot of time on that. And we spend a lot of time trying to make your build as fast as possible. But effectively it's that because the default, I'm trying not to go into the entire system of CircleCI, there's a lot to it,
这样你就可以把它们加载回来，因为依赖项解析需要一些时间。如果你在每次构建的每个实例中都这样做，那你就会浪费大量时间。我们花了很多时间试图让你的构建尽可能快。但实际上就是这样，因为默认情况下——我尽量不深入讲解CircleCI的整个系统，因为它内容很多——
but the default environment that your builds will run in is a Docker container or a set of Docker containers that you can compose together. And so you can actually build an image that's just like what you would use in production, either with those dependencies already installed or just make sure it's exactly the right version of Python, the same thing that you're using in development and plan to use in production
但你的构建运行的默认环境是一个Docker容器或一组可以组合在一起的Docker容器。所以你实际上可以构建一个镜像，就像你在生产环境中使用的一样，要么已经安装了那些依赖项，要么只是确保它是完全正确的Python版本，和你开发及计划在生产环境中使用的一模一样。
again pass the requirements.txt or gem file you know whatever it might be depending on the tools you're using um and then quickly re-establish that environment and then execute the tests in that environment um and then we throw it away so um other than what you can pass in and out through caches you're basically getting a clean environment all the time so you don't have that um i'm trying to keep using the python example so you know dot pyc file right where you like deleted the code but the compiled version is still cached there and so your code doesn't break until it gets into production yeah yeah because it was clean and doesn't have that file anymore and everything blows up yeah or you have you know
再次通过requirements.txt或gem file，你知道，取决于你使用的工具，然后快速重建该环境，并在该环境中执行测试，然后我们将其丢弃。所以，除了你可以通过缓存传入和传出的内容之外，你基本上每次都得到一个干净的环境。所以你不会有那种——我尽量继续使用Python的例子——比如.pyc文件，对吧？你删除了代码，但编译后的版本仍然缓存在那里，所以你的代码直到进入生产环境才崩溃。是的，因为环境是干净的，不再有那个文件，然后一切都炸了。是的，或者你有
10 000 python libraries on your computer and you have no idea which ones this code base is actually using well yeah i mean you deploy it on let's say circle ci and it's the tests are all gonna fail and they're gonna fail because package XYZ is missing, and you realize, oh, okay, I need that one. I don't need all 10,000 that are on my machine, but I definitely need that one. And you could kind of, at worst case, you could kind of golden line search, you know,
电脑上有10,000个Python库，你根本不知道这个代码库实际上在使用哪一个。嗯，是的，我的意思是，你把它部署在，比如说Circle CI上，所有的测试都会失败，它们会失败是因为缺少了包XYZ，然后你意识到，哦，好的，我需要那个。我不需要机器上的那10,000个，但我绝对需要那一个。你可以在最坏的情况下，进行某种黄金搜索，你知道，
and just eventually get all the packages that you need in there. But yeah, starting with a clean environment is a good way to guarantee that when you to guarantee that when someone else takes your code, that it works, or at least that you know that they have the bare essentials that's needed. virtual and for um yeah i'm trying to think of like the ruby version that we see is but um those sorts of things to say like this is my project these are the dependencies for this project only use those because it helps me find those problems faster yeah but the real problems like everyone has been through that experience of deploying something even if they have a very simple environment you know it's a single web server you put up your little flask app or whatever it might be, and it doesn't work. And then you sit there, you know, scrolling through syslog or wherever this stuff is ending up,
最终把你需要的所有包都放进去。但是，从一个干净的环境开始是保证当别人拿到你的代码时它能工作的好方法，或者至少你知道他们拥有所需的必要基础。虚拟环境，对于……是的，我在想我们看到的Ruby版本，但那些东西是为了说，这是我的项目，这是这个项目的依赖项，只使用这些，因为它能帮我更快地发现问题。是的，但真正的问题是，每个人都经历过部署某些东西的体验，即使他们有一个非常简单的环境，你知道，它是一个单一的Web服务器，你放上了你的小Flask应用或其他什么，但它不工作。然后你就坐在那里，你知道，滚动查看syslog或这些东西最终所在的地方，
trying to figure out what it was that you didn't do. And you're remoted into the machine. So you have this tiny terminal window, and I'm always too lazy to make it bigger, because I think I know the answer. So it's like, I'm looking at window and and uh trying to run vim through it and you know it's like it's like just this is just painful yeah anything you can do on your machine to not have to do that is a good thing yeah exactly and so trying to get you that that very similar environment in circle ci to vet those things, your dependencies, your versions, all of those other things that we don't, when we think about testing, we certainly, this is what we've been talking about the whole time. So me, myself included, we think about testing the code,
试图弄清楚你没做什么。而且你是远程连接到机器上的。所以你有一个很小的终端窗口，我总是太懒而不去把它调大，因为我觉得我知道答案。所以就像，我看着窗口，试图通过它运行vim，你知道，这简直是痛苦。是的，任何你在机器上能做的事情，为了不用那样做，都是一件好事。是的，完全正确。所以试图在Circle CI中为你提供那个非常相似的环境来验证那些东西，你的依赖项、你的版本，所有那些我们在考虑测试时，我们当然——这就是我们一直在谈论的。所以包括我在内，我们考虑的是测试代码，
right? Did I write the right logic in here? But also I want to make sure that my system is complete, right? And that i have all those pieces um and that's another thing that i'm going to like again the dependencies or whatever that i'm going to capture in a ci environment before i you know find out in production that i i don't know i mean even the version of the database that i'm using this is something that people do all the time honestly right yeah i use my mac os like homebrew or nix or whatever to install my sql but it's the latest instead of the one that we actually use in production and they fixed the bug or added a keyword or something and then i learned that so you know running your tests like
对吧？我在这里写了正确的逻辑吗？但我也想确保我的系统是完整的，对吧？而且我拥有所有那些部分，这是我会在CI环境中捕获的另一件事，在我在生产环境中发现之前，我不知道，我的意思是，甚至是我正在使用的数据库版本，这是人们一直在做的事情，老实说。对，我使用我的macOS，比如Homebrew或nix或其他什么来安装MySQL，但它是最新版本，而不是我们在生产环境中实际使用的那个，他们修复了一个bug或添加了一个关键字之类的，然后我才发现。所以，你知道，运行你的测试，比如
like saying in your um in your circle ci config i want to use to use MySQL 5.6.2 or whatever is actually in production, same thing, you're going to realize, oh, you know what? I wrote something that's not compatible with the one that we use in production. I'd rather find that out now than when I've deployed.
在你的Circle CI配置中说，我想使用MySQL 5.6.2或者生产环境中实际使用的任何版本，同样的事情，你会意识到，哦，你知道吗？我写的东西与我们在生产环境中使用的那个不兼容。我宁愿现在就发现，而不是在部署之后。
Yeah, that makes sense. And so to give people some, so people might not know what a Docker image is. I'm going to try my best. It's kind of a hard thing for me to wrap my head around but but basically imagine someone gave you um just a completely clean os so you started from scratch on you it could be windows linux whatever it is and then they said uh okay you know get your app up and running well you didn't you know you
是的，这很有道理。为了给人们一些……所以人们可能不知道什么是Docker镜像。我会尽力解释。这对我来说有点难理解，但基本上想象一下，有人给了你一个完全干净的操作系统，所以你是从零开始的，它可以是Windows、Linux，无论是什么，然后他们说，好的，让你的应用运行起来。好吧，你没有安装依赖项，你做了所有这些设置，你开始安装MySQL，你启动它，也许创建了数据库。所以有一些骨架，一些模式在那里，对吧？他们说，好的，现在我准备好运行我的应用了。对吧？所以Docker所做的是，它给了你创建镜像的能力，这基本上是你完成所有设置后的快照，然后在其中，你可以创建一个容器，它是该镜像的一个实例。换句话说，我有这个镜像，它说，好的，这是我需要的一切的空白板。在Circle CI的情况下，我可能想运行一百个测试，但我不想第99个测试受到第98个测试的影响。
didn't install the dependencies you do all of this setup, you'd start install MySQL, you'd start it, maybe create the database. So there's some, some, some skeleton, some schema there, right? They say, okay, now I'm ready to run my app. Right? So what Docker does is it, it gives you the ability to create an image, which is basically a snapshot after you've done all that setup and then within that and then you can create a container which is an instance of that image so in other words I have the image which says okay here is the the blank slate with everything that I need and and in the case let's say circle CI I might want to run a hundred tests but I don't want the 99th test to be influenced by the 98th test.
所以我可以根据那个镜像创建100个容器，每个容器运行一个测试。对，完全正确。所以我认为这是一个很好的总结。那么你是怎么做到的？我的意思是，这一定……你能给我们一些费米估算或者某种规模的概念吗？这绝对是令人震惊的，Docker镜像、Docker容器的数量，绝对是……因为你知道，任何人都可以免费在他们的项目上运行Circle CI。所以你们一定有成千上万的人。
So I could just create 100 containers based on that image and each container could run a test. Right, exactly. So I think that's a pretty good summary. So how do you do this i mean i mean so like it's just it must be just can you give us some like fermi estimation or some some like idea of the scale it must be absolutely astonishing the number of docker images docker containers like just absolutely because you know anyone can can run circle ci uh on their project for free. And so you must have just thousands and thousands of people.
我们确实有。让Docker在这方面表现出色的原因之一是——抱歉，在转到为什么Docker在这方面表现出色之前，先回答你的问题——我们正在运行成千上万个实例，就像我们能从各种云提供商那里获得的最大机器一样。然后在这些机器内部，我们将它们切分成
We do. One of the things that makes Docker great for this, and so sorry to actually answer your question before I move on to why Docker is great for this, we're running thousands of instances, like the largest machines that we can get from various cloud providers. And then within those, we're slicing them up
许多许多Docker容器，对吧？所以正如你所说，Docker镜像的实例。但是，Docker在搬运东西方面表现出色的原因是，Docker镜像是由层组成的。整个操作系统，对吧？原始Ubuntu镜像的层，你用包修改了它，你知道，依赖项，无论你安装了什么。当你保存它时，它在上面创建了一个层，
into many, many Docker containers, right? So as you said, like instances of Docker images. And, but what makes Docker great for this in terms of like shuttling things around is a Docker image is comprised of layers. the entire operating system, right? The layer of the original Ubuntu image and you modified it with the package, you know, the dependencies, whatever you installed. And that when you save that, it creates a layer on top
别人以不同的方式修改它，他们得到他们自己的层，但我们可以重用底层。并不是我们做了什么。我的意思是，这是Docker技术的一部分。所以我们只需要搬运很多这些小的层和位，对吧？明白了。
and somebody else modifies it differently and they get their own layer, but we can reuse the underlying layer. It's not that we do anything. I mean, this is part of the Docker technology. And so we only have to move around a lot of these small layers and bits, right? Got it.
所以我们可以缓存和重用常见的东西。比如我们的很多客户使用相同的MySQL实例，对吧？或者来自同一个镜像的相同MySQL版本。所以那个镜像已经在我们的大多数主机上了，这使得启动速度更快，意味着我们不需要在网络上搬运那么多东西。只是人们特定镜像的定制化内容在移动。事实上，我们提供所谓的便利镜像，它们针对我们的环境进行了优化。所以我们会采用数据库，我们会调整它们访问文件系统的方式等等，使其在CI环境中尽可能
So we can cache and reuse common things. Like a lot of our customers use the same MySQL instance, right? Or the same MySQL version from the same image. And so that image will be on most of our hosts already, which makes things faster to start up and means we don't have to move as many things around the network. It's just the customizations of, you know, in people's specific images that they move around. In fact, we provide what we call convenience images, which are optimized for our environment. So we'll take databases and we'll tune how they're accessing the file system and stuff like that to be as
快。因为老实说，如果系统崩溃了，你并不是在试图恢复测试中的数据，对吧？所以减少像F-Sync之类的事情来最小化开销并允许你的测试运行得更快，是我们花了很多时间做的事情，因为我们希望我们的客户能够尽可能快地完成他们的工作。而且因为我们提供这些高度调整的镜像，更多的客户会使用它们，这意味着我们也受益于将这些东西推送到所有正在运行的机器上。所以我们在网络上移动的东西更少，人们的构建运行得更快，
fast as possible in a CI environment. Because honestly, if the system crashes, it's not like you're trying to recover the data in your test, right? So reducing things like F-Sync and stuff like that to minimize overhead and allow your tests to run faster is something we spend a lot of time on because we want our customers to be able to get their job done as quickly as possible. And so because we provide these highly tuned images, more of our customers will use them, which means we also get the benefit of having that stuff, you know, pushed out to all the machines that are running. And so we move less stuff around the network and people's builds run even faster
因为他们正在访问我们已经为他们拉取的东西。这很有道理。所以你有成千上万个最大的实例。这大概是，我想机器可能是64核之类的，
because they're accessing stuff that we've already pulled down for them. That makes sense. So you have on the order of thousands of the largest instances. This would be, I guess, machines is maybe like 64 cores or something like that
还有大量的内存。我甚至不知道，TB级的内存之类的。还有大量的内存。我甚至不知道。TB级的内存。也许一半或更少。半TB的内存。是的。这取决于云提供商等等。所以，然后其中一个可以处理一定数量的Docker镜像。
and oodles of RAM. I don't even know, terabyte of RAM or something like that. And oodles of RAM. I don't even know. Terabyte of RAM or something. Maybe a half or less. Half terabyte of RAM. Yeah. It depends on the cloud provider and whatever. And so, and then one of those can handle like some number of Docker images.
这实际上看起来，所以有一种显著的效率。你知道，这里绝对有规模经济，因为我原以为那至少需要多出10倍的实例。是的，我的意思是，我们把东西打包进去，对吧？所以，当客户构建任何特别复杂的基准时，客户通常会构建出我们所谓的“工作流”，它由多个作业组成。这些作业可以并行或串行运行，我们基本上让你有能力定义一个图，对吧？这些是依赖项，这些是它们可以运行的时间。而那些实际的作业往往非常短。所以我们不断地……我的意思是，我们实际上使用了一个现成的作业调度器，叫做Nomad，由HashiCorp构建。
That actually seems, so there's a remarkable efficiency. You know, there's definitely an economy of scale here because i would have thought that that would have been like at least 10 times as many instances yeah i mean we we pack things in right and so um we when when a customer builds uh like any particularly complex um base, customer is generally going to build out what we call a workflow, which is comprised of multiple jobs. And the jobs can be run in parallel or in series, we basically give you the ability to define a graph, right? These are the dependencies, and this is when these can run. And those actual jobs tend to be quite short. And so we're constantly, I mean, we actually use an off-the-shelf job scheduler called Nomad, which is built by HashiCorp.
但它是在这个巨大的可用资源池中寻找，并说，我可以在哪里把这些打包进去？它们通常在几秒钟内就在机器上开启和关闭，对吧？所以如果你只是想尝试运行我们运行的量，并想象它们都像并行运行之类的，是的，规模要大几个数量级，但因为它们在短周期内运行，而且我的意思是，我们能够在有空间的地方把它们打包进去，这就是为什么我们使用我们能获得的最大机器，因为这样你可以更有效地打包，对吧？如果我有2x和4x和1x之类的东西，那么我可以把它们打包进一台机器，但如果我有小得多的机器，我会想，哦，我现在没有可用的那种，我得等，你知道之类的。所以，我们基本上只是制造了这个巨大的计算块，为了缺乏更好的词，然后它被分区以推动所有这些作业通过。所以是的，是的，然后它在几天的时间里循环，显然，我们的最高负载仍然是在太平洋时间中午左右，我们有全球各地的客户，但没有我们在硅谷忙碌时那么大的负载，我会说。所以我们扩大和缩小整个系统。我们轮换旧机器，以便我们可以进行补丁和安装东西。幕后发生了很多你可能不会想到的事情。但这就是
But it is looking in this giant pool of available resource and saying, where can I pack these in? And they're on and off machines often in seconds right so if you thought about just trying to run the volume that we run and imagined it all sort of like running in parallel or whatever yes the you know the orders of magnitude bigger but because they run in short cycles and they i mean we were able to pack them in wherever we have space um which is why we use the largest machines we can get because then you can pack it much more efficiently right if i've got like a 2x and a 4x and a 1x kind of thing then i can pack those into one machine but if you know if i have much smaller machines i'm like oh i don't
把这个提供给像我们这样的人的价值所在，对吧？因为如果你试图运行自己的CI系统，那是你会为自己的CI系统做的工作。因为我们不需要为那些你可能有的构建高峰拥有所有的过剩容量，因为我们的另一个客户刚刚停止构建，我们把它放进了同一个空间。对，这很有道理。正如你所说，我认为如果你自己做这件事，你要么会花一大笔钱，要么会浪费一大堆资源，要么你不可避免地会落后。所以，在下午4点59分，当每个人都试图赶上班车时，你的CI最终会落后三个小时，然后现在，你知道，在晚上8点，每个人
have one of those available right now i gotta wait you know whatever so um we basically just make this giant blob of compute for lack of a better word and that gets partitioned up to to push all these jobs through so yeah yeah and then it cycles over the course of the of days obviously like our our highest load is still midday pacific time sort of um we have customers all over the globe, but not quite as much load as we have when Silicon Valley is doing its thing, I would say. So we scale up and down that entire system. We rotate out old boxes so we can get patches and things in place. There's a lot happening behind the scenes that you probably wouldn't think about. But that's
都必须争先恐后地找出bug是如何引入的，你知道，当系统最终赶上时，对吧？是的，Circle CI通过说我们正在为你处理可扩展性来改善所有这些，这样你仍然可以立即得到结果。是的，我的意思是，无论在你的特定公司是什么时间，那个时间都存在，无论是一个下午2点的截止时间还是其他什么，而且这是一个非常基础的排队论问题，对吧？就像对我们这样的大规模来说，到达率看起来相当一致，对吧？是的。但在公司的微观层面，
what makes giving this to someone like us valuable, right? Because that's work that you would do for your own CI system if you were trying to run your own CI system. Because we don't have to have all the excess capacity for those spikes of builds that you might have as one of our customers, because one of our other customers just stopped building and we put it into that same space right yeah that makes sense and as you said i think that the if you if you're doing this yourself you're either going to spend a ton of money and you're going to have a whole bunch of wasted resources or you're going to inevitably fall behind so so at at 4 59 p.m when everyone's trying to catch the shuttle uh you're going to end up falling you know three hours behind on your ci and then now uh you know at at 8 p.m everyone
我的意思是，也要考虑月度，对吧？比如整个电子商务行业在11月中旬左右不会发布太多代码，因为他们正在为假日季节做准备，现在不是引入新东西的时候，它被锁定了，我们现在唯一需要做的就是确保我们有足够的在线容量，并且在进入一年中最重要的销售周期时不要破坏任何东西，对吧？所以你知道，他们没有使用太多的容量，然后但是当每个人都在试图让所有东西为那个准备好时，他们正在使用大量的容量。所以，你知道，它发生在一天、几周、几个月和一年的周期中。
has to scramble to find out how a bug got introduced you know when the system finally catches up right and yeah that circle ci kind of ameliorates all of that by saying we're you know handling the scalability for you so you can still get the results right away yeah i think that i mean whatever the time might be in your particular company that time exists right whether there's a 2 p.m cut off or you know whatever it might be um and it's like a pretty it's pretty 101 queuing theory kind of problem, right? Like if to us at such a large scale, the arrival rates look pretty consistent, right? Yep. But within the microcosm of a company,
我的意思是，我们在不同行业之间看到了这些非常大的差异，但它对我们来说是平稳的，因为我们有所有这些公司的一个很大的横截面。是的，这完全说得通。完全说得通。是的。我的猜测是，是的，但是那里，
I mean, think month to month also, right? Like there are the entire kind of e-commerce sector doesn't ship a lot of code starting maybe mid-November because they're getting ready for holiday season and it's not time to introduce new stuff like it's locked and all we need to do now is sort of make sure we have enough capacity online and not break anything right as we head into the most important sales cycle of the year and so you know they're using not a lot of capacity and then but as the you know in, as everyone's trying to get everything available for that, they're using a ton of capacity. And so, you know, it happens in the course of the day, the course of weeks, the course of months and over the cycle of the year.
是的，即使那样也有不同的产品，特别是不同的。一旦你进入世界不同的地区，不同的产品在不同的时间出来，不同的截止日期。所以你可以摊销，你知道，所有这些，所以……对，你不会得到这些巨大的峰值。
I mean, we see these really large kind of differences across different sectors and stuff, but it levels out for us because we just have such a big cross section of all these companies. Yeah, that totally makes sense. Totally makes sense. Yeah. My guess is yeah, but there,
是的，它平稳了。我的意思是，无论所有这些如何，我们都有巨大的客户，他们在特定时间出现巨大的工作负载，或者其他什么。所以我们花了很多时间优化我们能多快地让容量上线，这样如果我们发现自己陷入了巨大的峰值并且它开始等待，我们就会非常快地增加机器。我们优化每台机器的启动时间，所有这类事情，这样我们就可以增加那种容量。而且我们还保留了一个空闲缓冲池，无论你怎么考虑池，对吧？当然。一个空闲缓冲池，你知道，无论你怎么考虑池，对吧？当然。但是，是的，绝对像在大规模和更大规模上发生的平滑是一个巨大的优势。所以有一件事我肯定很多人在问，我们谈论了这么多次关于它是
yeah, even then there's different, different products, especially different. Once you go to different regions of the world, different products coming out at different times, different deadlines. And so you can amortize, you know, all of so that so that um right you don't get these huge spikes
免费的，而且它确实是免费的，如果你正在做任何类型的项目，我强烈建议使用它。我希望我在读博时使用过它，我不认为Circle CI在我读博时存在，但学到了很多惨痛的教训，所以一定要跳进去。但显而易见的问题是，如果一切都是免费的，你怎么赚钱？所以什么是定价，以及Circle CI作为一种业务是如何运作的？是的，所以我们实际上……赚钱对我们来说不是问题，我想这是简短的回答，但当然，但是……所以我们有一个基于使用的定价模型，这实际上是我们公司过程中的一个变化。过去是你购买一定量的容量，就像考虑你如何为你的房子购买
um yeah it levels out i mean we we do regardless of all of that we have you know we have huge customers who show up with huge you know workloads at a given time or whatever so we spend a lot of time um optimizing how fast we can get capacity online online so that if we ever get caught with a big spike and it's starting to wait, we bring machines on really quickly. We optimize the startup time of every machine, all that kind of stuff, so that we can just add that capacity. And we also keep a free buffer pool, however you would think about pools, right? Sure. a free buffer pool you know however you would think about pools right sure um but but yeah definitely like the the smoothing that happens at larger and larger scales is a is a great advantage for us so one thing i'm sure a lot of people are asking we talked so many times about how it's
带宽，你知道，无论你是否在使用，你都有这么多容量，如果你达到了那个容量的限制，那么你就等待。这很简单，人们理解它，从那个角度来看它很好，而且你有可预测性。但是，随着我们的成长，随着我们客户的成长，突然他们说，好吧，我们有数百名工程师在工作。我们不能让人等待。我们如何管理它？所以我们转向了基于使用的定价模型。
it's free and it is free and if you're doing anything uh any type of project i highly recommend using it i wish i used it on my phd i don't think circle ci was around when i was doing my phd but uh um learned a lot of lessons the hard way so definitely jump in there but then the obvious question is how do you make money right if everything is free and so where what's sort of the pricing and and what is like like how uh how does this how does circle ci work as sort of a business yeah so we actually um making money is not a problem for us i guess is the short answer to that but sure but uh you know so we we uh have a usage-based pricing model which is actually a change for us over the course of the company it used to be you bought a certain amount of capacity uh sort of think about how you buy
所以对于免费，我们基本上给你每个月有限数量的分钟，如果你是一个免费项目或小用户。我们为开源项目做更多，作为回馈社区的一种方式。我们使用很多开源，我们试图回馈代码，但也想支持开源社区，所以我们给他们更多的容量。明白了，这就解释了为什么，因为我有几个项目，我从来没有达到任何限制，而且我认为正如你所说，它们都是开源项目。是的，我的意思是，老实说，其中大多数，大多数开源项目只是构建得不多。是的，那也是真的。它就像一个小库。
bandwidth for your house you know it's like whether you're using or not you have this much capacity and if you hit the limit of that capacity then you wait um and that was simple and people understood it it was good from that perspective and you have predictability um but you know as we've grown and as our customers have grown you know suddenly they say, well, we have hundreds of engineers working. We can't make people wait. How do we manage that? So we shifted to a usage-based pricing model.
有人过来打了个补丁。但我们也有开源项目。所以PyTorch实际上是在CircleCI上构建的，是一个非常大的开源项目。有很多贡献者。它运行得很多，我们不能只是免费提供那种容量。是的，这很有道理。但在中间，但我们有很多商业客户，对吧？我们有客户，他们的整个工程组织有一千名工程师，或者无论什么，
And so for free, we basically give you a limited number of minutes per month sort of thing if you're a free project or a small user. We do more for open source projects as a means of giving back to that community we use lots of open source we try to contribute back to the code but also want to support the open source community um so we give them more capacity got it that explains why because i i have several projects i've never hit any limit um and i think it is as you said they're all open source projects yeah and i mean I mean, the majority of those, honestly, like the majority of open source projects just don't build that much. Yeah, that's true, too. It's like a little library.
整天都在Circle CI上构建，所以他们远远超过了免费限制。那么它是如何运作的呢？所以他们……我猜代码在某种意义上仍然是安全的。所以那些人……它不是通过GitHub，或者也许它仍然通过GitHub，但它是一个私有的……哦，我明白了，但它是一个私有仓库，所以他们的Docker镜像发给你，但没有其他人能看到它，然后你运行他们的测试，然后……是的，对，完全正确。我的意思是，我们在我描述的系统的所有这些部分之间有隔离，我们在构建之间擦除所有东西，并隔离网络，我的意思是，我们做了很多事情。啊，这很有道理，建立一个多租户系统，我们可以有这种打包
Someone comes along and gets a patch. But then we have open source projects. So PyTorch actually builds on CircleCI and is a very large open source project. A lot of contributors. It's running a lot, and we can't just give that kind of capacity away for free. Yep, that makes sense. But then in the middle, but we have a lot of commercial customers, right? We have customers whose entire engineering org of a thousand engineers or whatever um it's
并获得效率，而没有安全风险，对吧？所以，是的，他们……那将是他们的私有GitHub账户，你知道，他们所有的用户在他们的GitHub组织内都有GitHub用户。然后我们从那里拉取，拉取代码，找到他们想要使用的镜像。同样的过程，但我们为非常非常大的组织这样做。我的意思是，我们有广泛的组织，从那种车库里的两三个人，或者你知道，我们工作的地方，我想这可能是他们现在所在的地方，但是的，那是对的，也许我不知道会发生什么
built on circle ci all day every day and so they're they're well over the free limit uh so how does that work so they um i guess i guess the code is still safe in a sense so so so those folks um it's not through github or maybe it's still through github but it's a private oh i see but it's a private repository and so so their uh their docker image goes to you but it doesn't no one else can see it and then you run their tests and then yeah right exactly i mean we have isolation between all these parts of the system that i was describing and we wipe everything out in between builds and and isolate networks and i mean we do a lot of things ah that makes sense to build a multi-tenancy system where we can have this kind of packing
在WeWork，但我们会看到的。所以那个景观已经改变了。车库是笑话，虽然我从来没有真正在车库里工作过，但没有……所以你有两三个人，但如果他们一直在构建，那么他们就开始进入付费计划，但他们的使用量会很低。是的，有道理。再次，我们有上市公司在使用我们的平台，所以真的，真的很大的工程团队，工程组织内许多许多不同的团队在做移动端。我们有Linux和Windows和iOS或macOS。所以他们可以做多种事情。
and get the efficiency uh without the without the security risks right so um so yeah they there it'll be their private github account um and you know all of their users have GitHub users within their GitHub org. And then we're pulling from that, pulling the code down, finding the images that they want to use. Same process, but we do that for very, very large organizations. I mean, we have a broad spectrum of organizations from kind of the two, three people in a garage or where you know we work i guess is probably where they are now but yeah that's right maybe i don't know what's going
而这只是从他们的积分方面来自同一个容量池，对吧？所以他们基本上注册积分，然后使用它们来支持你的使用。明白了。如果有人不使用GitHub，他们还能使用CircleCI吗？那是什么样子的？
to happen at we work but we'll see so that that landscape has changed it was the garage was the joke when i although i've never actually worked out of a garage but no um so so you've got two three people but if they're building constantly then they're you know they're starting to move into the paid plan but their usage will be low. Yep, makes sense. Again, we have public companies using our platform, and so really, really large engineering teams, many, many different teams within the engineering organization doing mobile. We have Linux and Windows and iOS or macOS. So they can be doing a multitude of things.
是的，所以我们有对Bitbucket的支持，我们目前正在添加一些其他的。GitHub当然，对于基于云的版本控制，长期以来一直是主导者，但市场正在转变。
And that's just all coming out of that same capacity pool in terms of their credits, right? So they basically sign up for credits and then use them to support your usage. Got it. If someone isn't using GitHub, can they still use CircleCI? What does that look like?
是的，没错。我们看到人们有一段时间转向Bitbucket。我们看到人们转向GitLab或在GitLab上开始。所以是的，我们基本上支持多个。所以是的，我认为GitLab的挑战在于你可以托管你自己的GitLab。所以，是的，那会如何运作？所以有人在托管他们自己的GitLab。
Yeah, so We have support for Bitbucket and we're adding some others at the moment. GitHub has been, certainly for cloud-based version control, has been the dominant player for a long time, but the market is shifting.
他们还能使用CircleCI插件吗？比如，有这回事吗？是的，所以，嗯，有几件事。第一，我们确实有一个防火墙后的解决方案，或者我们称之为服务器。所以你可以自己运行CircleCI。当然，你会失去我刚才谈到的一些东西。是的，这很有道理。
Yeah, right. We had seen people going to Bitbucket for a while. We see people moving to GitLab or starting out on GitLab. So yeah, we basically support multiple. So yeah, I think the challenge with GitLab is you can host your own GitLab. And so, yeah, how would that work? So someone's hosting their own GitLab.
我们所做的一切来管理规模和不同类型的计算类型以及那些事情。但对于有专门团队来运行这类事情的大型组织，也许他们的源代码控制也在防火墙后面，并且想以那种方式工作。所以我们为GitHub Enterprise这样做。然后对于GitLab，我们现在正在做，它将是一种，我真的不知道如何描述，
Can they still use the CircleCI plugins? Like, is that a thing? Yeah, so, well, there's a couple things. One, we do actually have a behind-the-firewall solution, or we call it server. So you can take CircleCI and run it yourself. Of course, you lose some of the things I was talking about. Yeah, that makes sense.
但基本上是从服务器端回到我们云端的管道。是的，这很有道理。如果你安装了GitLab。而且，我的意思是，最终我们的客户倾向于来找我们，寻找的不仅仅是伟大的CI，比如在开发者体验和如何进行配置以及所有那些事情方面，而且还有我们管理它。因为这是我们可以提供的价值和我们可以承担的工作的另一个大步骤，这样他们就可以专注于，你知道，构建他们的产品。是的，这很有道理。所以，嗯，这太棒了。是的。所以只是为了总结一下CircleCI，然后我想跳到其他问题。嗯，每个人都应该使用CircleCI。所以每个人，试一试。嗯，希望
Everything that we do to manage the scale and different types of compute types and those sorts of things. But for large organizations that have dedicated teams to run this kind of thing and maybe they have their source control behind the firewall also and want to work in that way. So we do that for GitHub Enterprise. And then for GitLab, which we're working on now, it will be sort of a, I don't really know how to describe,
你正在使用GitHub或GitLab或Bitbucket。这些源之一，试一试。希望你正在使用GitHub或GitLab或Bitbucket或这些源代码控制之一用于你的个人项目。但如果你在高中，如果你在大学，看看这个。它会非常有用。我在一些项目中达到了一个地步，这是一个好主意，但没有任何测试，它变得太难了。我的意思是，有一次我在制作这个视频游戏。这是在高中，这是一个好主意，但没有测试，它变得太难了。我的意思是，有一次我在制作这个视频游戏，这是在高中，这是一个曲棍球游戏，你知道，我也来自多伦多，所以是一个大的曲棍球迷，我正在制作这个曲棍球，有一个bug，我必须把曲棍球游戏玩到第三节才能看到那个bug，我做了四次，我无法找出那个bug，它花了一个小时或
but basically a conduit back to our cloud from the server side. Yeah, that makes sense. If you have GitLab installed. And that, I mean, ultimately our customers tend to be coming to us looking for not just great CI, like in terms of the developer experience and how you do config and all those sorts of things, but also us managing it. Because that's another big step in the value that we can provide and work that we can take on so that they can focus on, you know, building their product. Yeah, that makes sense. So, um, yeah, this is amazing. Yeah. So just to, to wrap up the, the, the CircleCI a little bit, then I want to jump to some other questions. Um, everyone should use CircleCI. So everyone out there, try it out. Uh, hopefully
也许每次20分钟，所以我应该算了，我停止了那个项目的工作，你知道，不要像我一样，不要那样把自己逼进死胡同。如果你已经有那样的项目，你可以保存它们，你可以用好的测试拯救它们。我其实想问你面试过程是什么样的？所以首先，你们在招聘软件工程师、数据科学家，那些类型的人吗？
you're using GitHub or, or GitLab or Bitbucket. One of these source, try it out. Hopefully you're using GitHub or GitLab or Bitbucket or one of these source control for your personal project. But if you're in high school, if you're in college, check this out. It's going to be really useful. I've gotten to the point in some projects where it was a good idea, but without any tests, it just got too hard. I mean, at one point I was making this video game. This was in high school and it was a good idea but without any tests it just got too hard i mean at one point i was making this video game this was in high school and it was a hockey game you know i'm also from toronto so so a big hockey fan and i was making this hockey and there was a bug and i had to play the hockey game to the third period to see the bug and i did this like four times and i couldn't figure out the bug it took about an hour or
是的，绝对两者都是。所以我们有一个大的，我的工程组织大约有90人，并且在继续增长。所以我们总是在工程内部寻找各种角色的人。然后数据科学在我的团队之外。虽然在我的组织内，我们有一些人从产品角度处理数据。所以当你使用CircleCI时，对吧，了解我的构建运行得有多快？
maybe 20 minutes each time so I should forget it and I stopped working on the project right and you know don't don't be like me don't pay yourself in a corner that way uh if you if you already have projects like that you can save them you can rescue them with good tests um I actually wanted to ask you about what is the sort of interview process like so first of all are you hiring software engineers, data scientists, those kind of folks
每次都要花 20 分钟，所以我应该放弃它，于是我停止了那个项目。你知道，别像我一样，别把自己逼进死胡同。如果你已经有这样的项目，你可以通过良好的测试来挽救它们。我其实想问你，你们的面试流程是怎样的？首先，你们在招聘软件工程师、数据科学家这类人才吗？
yeah absolutely both so we have a large my engineering organization is about 90 people and continuing to grow. So we're always looking for people in various roles within engineering. And then data science sits outside of my team. Although within my organization, we have some folks working on data from a product perspective. So as you're using CircleCI, right, understanding how fast are my builds running?
是的，绝对都在招。我的工程团队大约有 90 人，并且还在持续增长。所以我们一直在寻找工程领域内各种角色的人才。数据科学团队不在我的部门内，尽管在我的组织架构中，我们确实有一些人从产品角度处理数据。比如当你使用 CircleCI 时，了解我的构建运行速度有多快？
What are the trends? Are there specific, you know, flaky tests or are there tests that are constantly failing that maybe we need to go work on? Like providing that kind of insight to our customers. So we have folks working on that. But then from a data science and analytics perspective, it's all we also do work around, you know, our business, how our business is functioning. And then from a product perspective, you know, how are people using this? Are they getting what they need? What can we do? You know, how can we change the way that our application works to provide them, you know, better, a better experience that will help them do what they're trying to do better. Right. So we, we, we take advantage of, um, of the data that we have. I
有哪些趋势？有没有特定的、你知道的、不稳定的测试，或者有没有持续失败的测试，也许我们需要去处理？比如向我们的客户提供这类见解。所以我们有人在做这件事。但从数据科学和分析的角度来看，我们也会围绕我们的业务，即我们的业务是如何运作的，开展工作。从产品的角度来看，人们是如何使用它的？他们得到了他们需要的东西吗？我们能做什么？你知道，我们如何改变应用程序的运作方式，为他们提供更好的体验，帮助他们更好地完成他们想要做的事情。对吧。所以我们利用我们拥有的数据。
mean, we've been running this system for eight plus years. We've hundreds of thousands of projects building every day. I mean, we have a lot of data is basically what I would say. Um, so yeah, we're, we're constantly looking for help across that whole spectrum. Yeah, so what's an interview like? So someone shows up straight out of college, shows up to CircleCI headquarters. What's the day going to look like for them? Well, interestingly, to start on that, we are actually distributed fairly globally in terms of our engineering team. So we tend to do a lot of interviewing remotely. We spend time talking to each other on video.
我的意思是，我们运行这个系统已经八年多了。我们每天有成千上万个项目在构建。我的意思是，我想说的是我们有很多数据。所以，是的，我们一直在整个范围内寻求帮助。那么面试是什么样的？如果有人刚从大学毕业，来到 CircleCI 总部。他们的一天会是什么样子？有趣的是，首先，就我们的工程团队而言，我们实际上是相当全球化分布的。所以我们倾向于进行大量的远程面试。我们花时间在视频上交谈。
And the process, effectively, there's a screen of some kind like any other. You submit your application or give us your resume and tell us a little bit about why you're interested in working with us. And then you would probably meet a hiring manager who would ask you some high-level questions about your focus, things that you've done. And then we do a coding challenge. This is an interesting thing, I think, in the industry that we've all gone around in different directions on but ours is a it's a homework assignment effectively or take home and we try to get you to time box it to two hours and you know you spend some time working on that problem and the goal is that you can then come have a conversation with us about what you did
这个过程实际上是这样的，像其他任何面试一样，会有某种筛选。你提交申请或给我们简历，并告诉我们你为什么有兴趣和我们一起工作。然后你可能会见到一位招聘经理，他会问你一些关于你的重点、你做过的事情的高层问题。然后我们进行编码挑战。我认为这是业内一件有趣的事情，我们都朝着不同的方向发展，但我们的是一个家庭作业，或者说是带回家的任务，我们尽量让你在两小时内完成，你知道，你花一些时间处理那个问题，目标是你之后可以来和我们讨论你做了什么。
because we've we've tried in the past doing live coding, you know, like I'll sit here and stare at you on video while you type. Yeah, right. That's painful. It's brutal. It's the process that I went through as we joined CircleCI because they wanted to vet us as engineers.
因为我们过去尝试过实时编码，你知道，就像我坐在这里，盯着视频里的你，而你在打字。是的，没错。那很痛苦。这很残酷。这就是我加入 CircleCI 时经历的过程，因为他们想审查我们作为工程师的能力。
And I was like, I swear I know how to write software, but I cannot in this moment remember how to write code because there's someone staring at me. And it's just very, it's not how software gets written. And the editor doesn't, doesn't give you any flexibility, right? I mean, it's like trying to run on concrete, you know what I mean? There's no tab completion. There's nothing. Yeah. Oh, well, well in this case we would, uh, we would screen share. So you would use your, oh, that's actually good, which is, which is a more, you know, more comfortable situation. It's certainly better than trying to write code on a whiteboard, I think.
当时我就想，我发誓我知道怎么写软件，但此刻我记不起怎么写代码了，因为有人盯着我。这真的不是写软件的方式。而且编辑器没有任何灵活性，对吧？我的意思是，这就像试图在混凝土上跑步，你明白我的意思吗？没有制表符补全。什么都没有。是的。好吧，在这种情况下，我们会进行屏幕共享。所以你会使用你的，哦，那其实很好，这是一种更舒适的情况。我认为这肯定比试图在白板上写代码要好。
Yeah. Right. And, you know, it's, I will say one of the places that I always do test-driven development is in a coding interview because someone will say, this is what I expected. I'll be like, okay, so if this test passes, then I have done the right thing. You know, it's a great way to, to validate that you, your understanding of requirements. But anyway, we don't do that anymore. But we do ask you to take home, you know, to take this thing that has some written code and you're going to work on it. And then come back and have a conversation. You know, what did you think of it? How did you make these decisions? What would you do next? Those sorts of things. Because it's a much more comfortable environment. You've taken some time to think about it how did you make these decisions what would you do next those sorts of things um because it's it's a much more comfortable environment you've taken some time to think
是的。没错。而且，我会说我在编码面试中总是进行测试驱动开发的地方之一，因为有人会说，这是我所期望的。我会说，好的，如果这个测试通过了，那么我就做对了。你知道，这是一种验证你对需求理解的好方法。但无论如何，我们不再那样做了。但我们确实要求你带回家，你知道，拿这个有一些书面代码的东西，然后你去处理它。然后回来进行对话。你知道，你觉得它怎么样？你是如何做出这些决定的？你接下来会做什么？诸如此类的事情。因为它是一个更舒适的环境。你花了一些时间去思考它，你是如何做出这些决定的，你接下来会做什么，诸如此类的事情，因为这是一个更舒适的环境，你花了一些时间去思考
about it and honestly most engineers that i know like to have some time to reflect on things uh and sort of digest them right it's in the moment uh it's not often the best for for software developers like in the moment it's kind of like quick banter about stuff especially when you're an expert the person asking the question has asked it a hundred times and then it can be so hard to be positive when the person's just kind of like yep yep yeah because they've just been through it so many times right and it's easy to feel like wow everyone at this company knows bubble sorts so well like so i'm so intimidated right but the reality is they've asked that question a thousand times right and so yeah interviewing is a big challenge so yeah i actually love this idea
它，老实说，我认识的大多数工程师都喜欢有一些时间来反思事情，并消化它们，对吧？在当下，对于软件开发人员来说，这通常不是最好的，在当下，这有点像关于事情的快速玩笑，特别是当你是一个专家时，问问题的人已经问过一百次了，当那个人只是像“是的，是的”那样时，要保持积极是非常困难的，因为他们已经经历过很多次了，对吧？很容易觉得，哇，这家公司的每个人都非常了解冒泡排序，所以我感到很害怕，但现实是他们已经问过那个问题一千次了，对吧？所以，是的，面试是一个巨大的挑战，所以我其实很喜欢这个想法
of of sort of this homework assignment and then you can have just like a more socratic discussion right right exactly like you've had some time to think about it. This is like, this is the, it's closer to the real world. Like tell me what your experience was. And then we sort of talk through it and ask some specific questions. Maybe ask some questions about choices you made or like whether you, and whatever.
关于这种家庭作业，然后你可以进行更苏格拉底式的讨论，对吧？没错，完全正确，就像你有一些时间去思考它一样。这更接近现实世界。告诉我你的经历是什么。然后我们讨论一下，问一些具体的问题。也许问一些关于你所做选择的问题，或者关于你是否，等等。
So I'm not gonna give you too much detail because we still use the same process. Oh, sure, sure. Yeah, yeah, no spoilers. And then we have another sort of more higher level system design level or system design oriented um discussion and in that case we sort of talk you through what we're looking for and you would talk to us about how you would design the system in certain ways to meet those uh those requirements um and then uh and then we do a more product oriented conversation which is usually more um based
所以我不会给你太多细节，因为我们仍然使用相同的流程。哦，当然，当然。是的，没有剧透。然后我们还有另一种更高级别的系统设计或以系统设计为导向的讨论，在这种情况下，我们会和你讨论我们正在寻找什么，你会和我们讨论你将如何以某种方式设计系统以满足这些要求，然后我们进行一次更以产品为导向的对话，这通常更多是基于
off of your experience uh and so this is interesting because you're talking about kind of new grads and we we adapted a little bit for that but um even i mean you just talked about building a game in high school like like new grads from college. I'll say these days because I'm that old guy. Like I did not I had not built a game by the time I graduated from college. Like I basically knew a tiny little bit about software development. Right. So, you a product management group, if you've had that experience, or how you think about the customer and break down the problem and stuff like that. A little bit outside of the CS fundamentals perspective and more into real work as a software engineer. As a software engineer, as much as we like to ask questions about, well, we don't ask a lot of questions about bubble sort but like we don't all spend our days writing bubble sort over and over right like we're trying to solve customer problems we're trying to help them you know have a great
你的经验，这很有趣，因为你在谈论应届毕业生，我们为此做了一些调整，但即使是你刚才谈到在高中建立一个游戏，就像大学应届毕业生一样。我会说这些天，因为我是那个老家伙。我大学毕业时还没有建立过游戏。我基本上只知道一点点关于软件开发的知识。对吧。所以，产品管理小组，如果你有那种经验，或者你是如何思考客户并分解问题等等。从计算机科学基础的角度来看，这有点超出了范围，更多的是作为软件工程师的实际工作。作为一名软件工程师，尽管我们喜欢问关于冒泡排序的问题，但我们并不是每天都在反复写冒泡排序，对吧？我们试图解决客户的问题，我们试图帮助他们，你知道，在我们的平台上拥有很棒的
experience on our platform and we're trying to prioritize with a limited number like a limited team uh all of the things that we could go pursue and really drive maximum value for the business and for the customer. And so that's a big part of what we do every day. And so really having a conversation about that and kind of understanding how people think about those sorts of scenarios, how they think about breaking down work and validating things. And of course, we live in this iterative, agile world, you know, kind of experiences with that. Yeah, that makes sense. And people could do a lot of this in college. You know, I think that if you work on a team, so if you have a senior design project, you're going to you're going to have to coordinate and you're going to deal with a lot of these issues.
体验，我们试图在一个有限的团队中优先考虑我们可能追求的所有事情，并真正为业务和客户创造最大价值。所以这是我们每天所做工作的重要组成部分。所以真正进行关于那方面的对话，并理解人们如何思考这类场景，他们如何思考分解工作和验证事情，这真的很重要。当然，我们生活在这个迭代的、敏捷的世界里，你知道，那种经验。是的，这很有道理。人们在大学里可以做很多这样的事情。你知道，我认为如果你在一个团队中工作，如果你有一个高级设计项目，你将不得不协调，你将不得不处理很多这些问题。
And and yeah, I think one piece of advice we give a lot of folks is just build stuff. You know, as you build things, you're going to realize we talked about tests, but you realize a lot of different. You'll have to sort of plan your time. You'll have things that other people want from the thing you built that you might not be able to fulfill. Right. So you have to prioritize that. And these are all really good experiences that anyone could have right now um yeah so you said you're distributed so that means that if someone is in i don't know london they stay in london like like how does that whole thing work is there a lot of communication on slack like what's a distributed company like yeah so um we have specific uh countries at this point where we're incorporated or have
是的，我认为我们给很多人的一条建议就是去构建东西。你知道，当你构建东西时，你会意识到我们谈论的测试，但你会意识到很多不同的东西。你将不得不规划你的时间。你会有其他人想要你构建的东西，而你可能无法满足。对吧。所以你必须优先考虑这一点。这些都是任何人现在都可以拥有的非常好的经验。是的，所以你说你是分布式的，这意味着如果有人在伦敦，我不知道，他们就留在伦敦，整个事情是怎么运作的？Slack 上有很多交流吗？分布式公司是什么样的？是的，所以我们在目前我们注册或拥有
entities and so um that includes japan uk uh ireland germany canada and the u.s um and and yes so most of the people outside of um outside of san francisco so our headquarters is in san francisco but there's actually a very small portion of the engineering team in san francisco Outside of San Francisco. So our headquarters is in San Francisco, but there's actually a very small portion of the engineering team in San Francisco, like marketing, finance, revenue. We have a bunch of people in San Francisco. So mostly people are working from home
实体的特定国家，包括日本、英国、爱尔兰、德国、加拿大和美国。是的，所以旧金山以外的大多数人，我们的总部在旧金山，但实际上旧金山的工程团队比例非常小。旧金山以外。我们的总部在旧金山，但实际上旧金山的工程团队比例非常小，比如市场营销、财务、收入。我们在旧金山有一群人。所以大多数人是在家里工作
kind of in these different areas. We do have an office in Toronto, actually. Oh, cool. And Zoom. We use a lot of zoom a lot of slack um we uh we try to organize ourselves in a way that the time zones are not too challenging but it depends you know different teams have different yeah that is a very hard problem right i mean because you have in your case you mentioned japan and then you have london that's what 12 hours or something right yeah um yeah so there's well actually that that kind of ends up being eight eight how does it work uh yeah sort of like tokyo to san francisco is about eight hours
在这些不同的领域。我们实际上在多伦多有一个办公室。哦，酷。还有 Zoom。我们使用很多 Zoom，很多 Slack。我们试图以一种时区不太具有挑战性的方式组织自己，但这取决于，你知道，不同的团队有不同的，是的，那是一个非常困难的问题，对吧？我的意思是，因为在你的情况下，你提到了日本，然后你有伦敦，那是 12 小时还是什么的，对吧？是的，所以实际上这最终是 8 小时，它是怎么运作的？是的，东京到旧金山大约是 8 小时
oh okay san francisco to london or dublin is about eight hours yeah so if you try to make a meeting with people in three places right somebody has a terrible time. We try not to have, you know, one team that spans, you know, all three. I think we have one that's, that's got, you know, too many time zones right now. It always happens, but we, you know, we try to organize ourselves. And as we, as we continue to grow, it becomes easier to say, you know what, we'll just build this whole team in Europe or we'll build this whole team in West Coast. West Coast North America plus Tokyo or something like that, right? When you're smaller and you just have one expert or two experts in this thing and they happen to be in different time zones, you're like, well, you're on the same team now. So it can be a challenge but yeah a lot of we we try to um do as much async as we can it can be challenging
哦，好的，旧金山到伦敦或都柏林大约是 8 小时。是的，所以如果你试图在三个地方和人们开会，对吧，有人会过得很糟糕。我们尽量不让一个团队跨越所有三个地方。我想我们现在有一个跨越太多时区的团队。这种情况总是发生，但我们尽量组织自己。随着我们继续成长，说“你知道吗，我们将整个团队建立在欧洲，或者我们将整个团队建立在西海岸”变得更容易了。西海岸北美加上东京之类的，对吧？当你规模较小，并且在这个领域只有一两个专家，而他们恰好在不同的时区时，你会想，好吧，你们现在在同一个团队。所以这可能是一个挑战，但我们尽量尽可能多地进行异步工作，这可能具有挑战性
it can create some overhead but it's also it creates some positives right like i think there's things that we end up doing when we're all co-located um that we would break the habit as we're distributed like documenting things effectively. Oh, that's a good point. Our decisions are, you know, where it sort of forces practices that are actually good practices, even if you're all together. And actually, my favorite thing to call out, that's a great practice. And, you know, people say, how do you know that people are getting, you know, are doing their job, right, In a distributed team. And when, when someone asked me that, it makes me think that when you're
它可能会产生一些开销，但它也产生了一些积极因素，对吧？就像我认为当我们都在同一个地方时，我们最终会做一些事情，当我们分布式时，我们会改掉这些习惯，比如有效地记录事情。哦，那是一个很好的观点。我们的决定是，你知道，它强制执行了实际上是好习惯的做法，即使你们都在一起。实际上，我最喜欢指出的事情是，这是一种很好的做法。而且，你知道，人们说，你如何知道人们在分布式团队中是否在做他们的工作，对吧？当有人问我这个问题时，这让我想起当你
centrally located, asking me that question, your approach to, are you doing your job is, are you in your seat from nine to five? Right. But I can't tell if anyone's in their seat, like you might be at home or you might be in a coffee shop or you might actually be in another country right now. It's hard for me to know. what am i going to measure what am i going to think about and i honestly i'm like there are a couple layers of management between me and sort of individual engineers or whatever but um we talk about results like are we are we having the impact that we said we were going to have as a team over the course of this period and if we did that then we're probably doing our jobs effectively and if we didn't most likely some other thing is causing problems right but if it
集中办公时，问我那个问题，你对“你是否在做你的工作”的方法是，你是否从九点到五点坐在你的座位上？对吧。但我无法判断是否有人坐在他们的座位上，就像你可能在家里，或者你可能在咖啡店，或者你现在可能实际上在另一个国家。我很难知道。我要衡量什么？我要考虑什么？老实说，我像是在我和个人工程师之间有几层管理，或者其他什么，但我们谈论的是结果，我们是否正在产生我们作为团队在这段时间内说要产生的这种影响？如果我们做到了，那么我们可能正在有效地做我们的工作，如果我们没有，很可能其他事情导致了问题，但如果
becomes clear that someone is just not producing then you know a manager is going to have a conversation with that person and say hey like what's up seems like maybe you're having some challenges do you not have the you know do you not have the information you need do you know do you not do you need someone to pair with you like there's a lot of things that could be going wrong we know we don't jump straight to like this person or whatever but um i think in when we're co-located we we have this crutch of like people are here and they seem busy so probably yeah that's fascinating you know i think i think um yeah there's this sort of dual problem, which is, um, which is if you're not co-located, someone might not work a lot of hours and, and, and they might not be around, you know, actually working a lot, but then they could get their job done. So potentially, maybe there's somebody, especially if you're paying salary, there's someone who, for whatever reason,
很明显有人就是没有产出，那么经理会和那个人谈话，说“嘿，怎么了？看起来你可能遇到了一些挑战，你没有你需要的信息吗？你需要有人和你配对吗？”有很多事情可能会出错，我们知道我们不会直接跳到“这个人”之类的，但我认为当我们集中办公时，我们有这种拐杖，就像人们在这里，他们看起来很忙，所以可能，是的，这很迷人，你知道，我认为，是的，存在这种双重问题，即如果你不是集中办公，有人可能不会工作很多小时，他们可能不会在周围，你知道，实际上工作很多，但他们可以完成他们的工作。所以潜在地，也许有人，特别是如果你在支付工资，有人因为某种原因，
they're getting some unit of work done, but they're not taking that much time. But actually, that's not a big deal. The big deal is the reverse, where someone's spending a ton of time, and they're actually not getting that much done. And so I think that to your point, the crutch actually can end really badly where somebody is just always in the office. And often this is because they've sort of misscoped the problem. So they haven't managed up very well. And there's this problem that's actually extremely difficult. But because of the way it's been communicated,
他们完成了一些工作单元，但他们没有花那么多时间。但实际上，这没什么大不了的。大问题是相反的，有人花了很多时间，但实际上并没有完成那么多工作。所以我认为，就你的观点而言，这种拐杖实际上可能以非常糟糕的方式结束，有人总是待在办公室。通常这是因为他们对问题进行了错误的范围界定。所以他们没有很好地向上管理。有一个实际上极其困难的问题。但由于沟通方式的原因，
it sounds like it should be pretty easy. And then this person spends an extraordinary amount of time and then still doesn't perform well. Versus if you're remote, you know that the time isn't being watched. And so if you're not meeting the, you know that the time isn't being watched. And so if you're not meeting the, if you aren't completing this work package,
听起来应该很容易。然后这个人花了大量的时间，但仍然表现不佳。相比之下，如果你是远程的，你知道时间没有被监视。所以如果你没有达到，你知道时间没有被监视。所以如果你没有达到，如果你没有完成这个工作包，
you're going to pretty early on go and tell your boss, hey, this is actually really hard. And I'm spending a ton of time on this. I'm not getting it done. If you have the crutch, you might just assume your boss is seeing you there. And most companies don't. At the end of the day, what's going to matter is, is that work package done?
你很早就去告诉你的老板，“嘿，这实际上真的很难。我花了很多时间在这上面。我没有完成它。”如果你有那个拐杖，你可能只是假设你的老板看到你在那里。大多数公司不会。归根结底，重要的是那个工作包是否完成了。
Right, right. Or, well, I mean, we also spend a lot of time trying to translate that into impact, right? Because there's kind of two things that happen there. One, I've taken on a thing that felt like it would be easy. It's actually really hard. And that can be challenging remote because if you're not comfortable raising your hand, then you're even less comfortable like shouting into Slack or whatever. Hey, I don't know what I'm doing. Can someone please help me? Which you should totally be comfortable doing that. But you know, people struggle with that. And the other though, is you take on work, which actually turns out to be hard,
对吧，对吧。或者，我的意思是，我们也花了很多时间试图将其转化为影响，对吧？因为那里发生了两件事。第一，我承担了一件感觉很容易的事情。它实际上真的很难。这在远程办公中可能具有挑战性，因为如果你不习惯举手，那么你在 Slack 或其他地方大喊大叫就更不舒服了，“嘿，我不知道我在做什么。有人能帮帮我吗？”你应该完全习惯这样做。但你知道，人们对此感到挣扎。但另一方面，你承担了工作，实际上证明是困难的，
assuming because you've made this connection at some point, you know, with your product team or whatever, this work is going to drive this impact. And if it turns out as you get through it, the work is not driving the impact the way that you expected, where impact would be, you know, more users signing up, people having a better time on the platform, they're engaging with something, whatever, you should stop. You should at least stop and have a conversation and say, hey, we set out to do this thinking it was going to do this for our users or drive this value for the business. And it doesn't seem to be doing that. So, you know, let's not just keep charging down this path. Let's make sure we're checking in at least and saying, hey, did we misread something? Are we just too early? You know, is the signal delayed? How do we feel? Should we continue to invest or should we should we take on something else? you're trying to deliver and you surface those conversations then um it's it's a easier to make
假设因为你在某个时候与你的产品团队或其他什么建立了这种联系，这项工作将推动这种影响。如果当你完成它时，工作并没有像你预期的那样推动影响，其中影响将是，你知道，更多的用户注册，人们在平台上玩得更开心，他们正在参与某事，无论什么，你应该停止。你应该至少停下来进行对话，说，“嘿，我们着手做这件事，认为它会为我们的用户做这件事，或者为业务推动这种价值。它似乎并没有这样做。所以，让我们不要只是继续沿着这条路走下去。让我们确保至少检查一下，说，嘿，我们是否误读了什么？我们是否太早了？你知道，信号是否延迟了？我们感觉如何？我们应该继续投资，还是应该承担其他事情？”你试图交付，你浮现这些对话，那么，A，更容易确保
sure that you know that folks are all engaged and they're succeeding and whatever um and b it's just better for your business yeah yeah that makes sense so i have this theory and the theory might might not hold water but let's let's assume it doesn't go from there i have this theory that once you hit 200 engineers, that you inevitably end up with warring factions, and you can't stop it. You just hit some critical mass, and what happens is there ends up being this sort of fragmented identity.
人们都参与其中，他们正在成功，等等，B，这对你的业务更好。是的，是的，这很有道理。所以我有一个理论，这个理论可能站不住脚，但让我们假设它不成立，从那里开始。我有一个理论，一旦你达到 200 名工程师，你不可避免地会以交战的派系告终，你无法阻止它。你只是达到了某个临界质量，发生的事情是最终出现了一种碎片化的身份。
So, for example, you hit this large enough org, and now the researchers and the engineers aren't getting along. Maybe the engineers who are doing more on the research side and the more applied engineers have split up. And it's not obviously in the org chart. I mean, the leaders don't necessarily want that to happen. But it's an organic thing that once you get to this size, it seems hard to have a common identity you don't really see the existential threat um or the existential uh yeah i guess threat for lack of a better word and the internal threat starts to sort of reach parity right um and so circle ci is that i think you said 90 engineers so you're halfway there so but but you could kind of forecast like like how do you deal
例如，你达到了这个足够大的组织，现在研究人员和工程师相处得不好。也许在研究方面做更多工作的工程师和应用更多的工程师分开了。这在组织结构图中并不明显。我的意思是，领导者不一定希望这种情况发生。但这是一个有机的过程，一旦你达到这个规模，似乎很难拥有一个共同的身份，你并没有真正看到生存威胁，或者生存，是的，我想说威胁，因为没有更好的词，内部威胁开始达到平衡，对吧？所以 CircleCI 是，我想你说的是 90 名工程师，所以你已经走了一半了，但你可以预测，你如何处理
with this where you know maybe maybe a team says you know has a really strong team identity but then that team always seems to be battling with other teams right um how do you sort of you know balance that against sort of another team that maybe doesn't have a strong identity and then they can't really execute and retain talent right that's how do you sort of strike that balance yeah it's a really interesting question i mean i think you kind of i'm going to take your lead on something you said in there which is the the existential threat being replaced by an internal threat, right? And I think threats are not the, your greatest hope of alignment is clear top level vision.
这个问题，你知道，也许一个团队说，你知道，有一个非常强大的团队身份，但那个团队似乎总是与其他团队战斗，对吧？你如何平衡这一点，与另一个可能没有强大身份的团队相比，他们无法真正执行和留住人才？那是你如何平衡这一点？是的，这是一个非常有趣的问题，我的意思是，我认为你有点，我将采取你在其中所说的一些东西，即生存威胁被内部威胁所取代，对吧？我认为威胁不是，你对齐的最大希望是清晰的最高层愿景。
And I'm not saying that we're amazing at this. Like this is something that I'm constantly spending my time thinking about and trying to help be clearer about. And when people in multiple teams all see the same direction and buy into that direction, I think that does a lot to tamp down that kind of, I'll call it infighting or whatever you're describing. In that when you get to this place where you feel like your reason for being is your team as opposed to the company, then that's where that starts, right? So you think, okay, I, you know, we really want to do this thing and that's important
我并不是说我们在这一点上很棒。就像这是我一直在花时间思考并试图帮助变得更清晰的事情。当多个团队中的人们都看到同一个方向并认同那个方向时，我认为这在抑制你所描述的那种内斗或其他什么方面做了很多工作。当你到达这个地方，你觉得你存在的理由是你的团队而不是公司时，那就是开始的地方，对吧？所以你认为，好的，我，你知道，我们真的想做这件事，这很重要
to us and therefore we're going to do it and we're going to do it, you know, to the detriment of this other team or whatever. Whereas when you feel like we're really driving towards this bigger goal together, then you look at this other team and say, hey, you know, we kind of need a thing. You need a thing. Like, how can we work together to figure out the best outcome for all of us, right? And I think that there's a couple things in there. The top level vision, direction, people being aligned around that is really, really critical. But then that has to happen down through layers of management, right? So, I mean, at some point, though, to your point of the org chart, at some point, those two teams fall under the same person. Right. And it might be all the way up at the CEO, but quite likely it's, you know, a manager, like an engineering manager or a director or something like that. Right. And that person should have clarity about their mission. Right. OK, if this is the mission of the company, this is our mission. Right. This is what we're doing that supports that. And being able to connect those dots is really important for people. Right. Like feeling like I work on a thing day to
对我们来说，因此我们将去做它，我们将去做它，你知道，损害了其他团队或其他什么。而当你觉得我们真的在共同推动这个更大的目标时，那么你看着另一个团队说，嘿，你知道，我们有点需要一个东西。你需要一个东西。就像，我们如何共同努力找出对我们所有人最好的结果，对吧？我认为其中有几件事。最高层的愿景、方向、人们围绕它保持一致是非常非常关键的。但这必须通过管理层向下发生，对吧？所以，我的意思是，在某种程度上，就你的组织结构图的观点而言，在某种程度上，这两个团队属于同一个人。对吧。它可能一直到 CEO，但很可能是，你知道，经理，比如工程经理或总监之类的。对吧。那个人应该对他们的使命有清晰的认识。对吧。好的，如果这是公司的使命，这就是我们的使命。对吧。这就是我们正在做的支持它的事情。能够连接这些点对人们来说非常重要。对吧。就像觉得我每天都在做一件事
day and I don't know why it's related. And we see this. We see this. But I don't know why it's related to the overall goal of the company is really bad. That's not a fun feeling, right? When you talk about retaining talent, feeling like you don't know what the value that you bring, or you don't know, yeah, you don't know the value that you bring to the company. It's not a fun feeling, right? So being able to connect that and then being driven by, honestly, a smaller mission that aligns with the bigger mission that's easier to connect to your day-to-day work. Right.
，我不知道为什么它相关。我们看到了这一点。我们看到了这一点。但我不知道为什么它与公司的整体目标相关，这真的很糟糕。那不是一种有趣的感觉，对吧？当你谈论留住人才时，觉得你不知道你带来的价值，或者你不知道，是的，你不知道你为公司带来的价值。那不是一种有趣的感觉，对吧？所以能够连接这一点，然后被老实说，一个与更大的使命相一致的更小的使命所驱动，这更容易连接到你的日常工作。对吧。
So, um, for example, like I talk about, I talked a bunch about, um, how much we care about the speed of, of builds running. Right. And so ultimately our customers are happier when their stuff runs well, runs quickly on our system, and they can get their job done, right? And so we get more customers as a company, we're more successful. But if I work on a team that, you know, provisions hardware, not that the team provisions hardware, but builds tools that scales our fleets up and down, then I can directly connect, you know, my ability to make sure there's capacity
所以，例如，我谈论了很多关于我们多么关心构建速度的事情。对吧。所以最终我们的客户在他们的东西运行良好、在我们的系统上运行迅速时更快乐，他们可以完成他们的工作，对吧？所以我们作为一家公司获得了更多的客户，我们更成功。但如果我在一个团队工作，你知道，配置硬件，不是说团队配置硬件，而是构建工具来扩展我们的机群，那么我可以直接连接，你知道，我确保有容量的能力
online, countered against the money that we spend with customers happiness, right. And so I see impact on the, you know, the top level kind of company and customer based on how I'm able to do my job really effectively. And so rallying around that, I mean, it's kind of a contrived example, but rallying around that allows me and probably a few other teams around me, right? Maybe I need some people who know more about our operational deployments. Maybe I need some people who've built some upstream code or whatever. Like when we see that shared goal, then we can work on it together instead of being about like my team, right? Yeah, that makes sense. So what about when you have sort of things that are more zero sum?
在线，与我们花费的钱和客户的幸福感相抵消，对吧。所以我看到对顶层公司和客户的影响，基于我能够多么有效地完成我的工作。所以围绕这一点团结起来，我的意思是，这是一个有点牵强的例子，但围绕这一点团结起来允许我和我周围可能还有其他几个团队，对吧？也许我需要一些更了解我们运营部署的人。也许我需要一些构建了一些上游代码或其他什么的人。就像当我们看到那个共同的目标时，那么我们可以一起努力，而不是关于我的团队，对吧？是的，这很有道理。那么当你有一些更零和的事情时呢？
So for example, there's a team that's trying to reduce the compute, you know, reduce the bottom line, right? So it's not take such a hit on compute. There's another team is trying to make people happier by giving them quicker builds. But that that costs money. And so I guess that's one of those things where I guess the you we probably have like another hour and a half on organizational design or whatever, but that's like, it's a really interesting problem where like, I wouldn't want to end up in a situation where one team is responsible for cost and another is responsible for like that customer happiness, but rather those are themes that we understand at a top level and then down through
例如，有一个团队试图减少计算，你知道，减少底线，对吧？所以它不会在计算上受到那么大的打击。另一个团队试图通过给他们更快的构建来让人们更快乐。但这需要花钱。所以我想这是其中之一，我想你可能还有关于组织设计或其他什么的一个半小时，但这就像，这是一个非常有趣的问题，就像，我不想最终处于一个团队负责成本而另一个负责客户幸福的情况，而是这些是我们理解的顶层主题，然后向下通过
the org. And then my team, let's say in this case, I'm describing as responsible for job allocation and job execution, right? And so I don't worry about user interfaces and how config gets written and other stuff, but I worry about once we know something needs to get run we're going to get it run as quickly as possible and i am optimizing performance and cost against each other right yeah that makes sense i i own a domain or whatever and i know these are big parameters for the company and so i can reason about how to balance these things you know if someone else that totally makes sense and i own job allocation like we're gonna have a really sad time like yeah that's right it's like someone was i was joking about this earlier but like this classic comic of you know two people digging ditches behind each other and they're like yeah that's another hole right like just
组织。然后我的团队，假设在这个例子中，我描述为负责作业分配和作业执行，对吧？所以我不用担心用户界面以及配置是如何编写的和其他东西，但我担心一旦我们知道某件事需要运行，我们将尽可能快地运行它，我正在优化性能和成本，对吧？是的，这很有道理。我拥有一个领域或其他什么，我知道这些是公司的大参数，所以我可以推理如何平衡这些事情，你知道，如果其他人，这完全有道理，我拥有作业分配，就像我们将有一个非常悲伤的时间，就像，是的，那是对的，就像有人，我之前在开玩笑，但就像这个经典的漫画，你知道，两个人互相在后面挖沟，他们就像，是的，那是另一个洞，对吧？就像只是
basically making each other's lives miserable and running in place um and so so it's one of the things that you try to think about in structuring both goals and teams is being able to align that big picture without partitioning them in that way. Yeah, that totally makes sense. Yeah, I think if you can take those zero-sum situations, like machines versus people's happiness, and basically break them down
基本上让彼此的生活变得悲惨，并在原地奔跑，所以这是你在构建目标和团队时试图思考的事情之一，即能够对齐大局，而不以那种方式划分它们。是的，这完全有道理。是的，我认为如果你能采取那些零和情况，比如机器与人们的幸福，并基本上分解它们
so that every team has the zero sum then uh then yeah they're not they're not in this position yeah that's that's a really great answer i appreciate it that's something that i was kind of kind of been mulling about so it's great to get your get your take on it um cool so how can people reach you if people want to apply to circleCI? How can they do that? What are the best ways to reach out? So we, I mean, circleci.com slash, you know, everything that we have currently open. To reach me, I'm on Twitter at Zub, with Z-0-0-B.
以便每个团队都有零和，那么是的，他们就不会处于这个位置，是的，那是一个非常好的答案，我很感激。这是我一直在思考的事情，所以很高兴得到你的看法，酷，那么如果人们想申请 CircleCI，人们怎么能联系到你？他们怎么能做到？联系的最佳方式是什么？所以我们，我的意思是，circleci.com 斜杠，你知道，我们目前开放的一切。要联系我，我在 Twitter 上是 @Zub，Z-0-0-B。
Oh, nice. I don't know how to spell it. Yeah, cool. I've been dragging that around for a while. Oh, nice. I have to spell it. Yeah, cool. I've been dragging that around for a while. That's awesome. Yeah. Or, I don't know. I mean, I'm usually out there somewhere.
哦，不错。我不知道怎么拼写它。是的，酷。我已经拖着那个东西有一段时间了。哦，不错。我必须拼写它。是的，酷。我已经拖着那个东西有一段时间了。那太棒了。是的。或者，我不知道。我的意思是，我通常在某个地方。
Cool. Some conference or something like that. Oh, yeah. It's not that hard to track down. LinkedIn, I guess, if people are interested. Cool. Although, Twitter is probably easier if you don't know me because I i don't yeah they could just necessarily respond to everything on linkedin yeah totally makes sense so circleci.com slash jobs and um oh i didn't ask this but you have internships or just full-time
酷。某个会议之类的。哦，是的。追踪它并不难。LinkedIn，我想，如果人们感兴趣的话。酷。虽然，Twitter 可能更容易，如果你不认识我，因为我，我，不，是的，他们不一定非要在 LinkedIn 上回复所有内容，是的，完全有道理，所以 circleci.com 斜杠 jobs，而且，哦，我没有问这个，但你有实习生还是只有全职
uh currently just full-time okay um it's something that we are trying to figure out how we can do better um it is one of the challenges of remote. We do have, like I said, we have an office in San Francisco and one in Toronto, but they're not particularly large. And so for internships, we always want to make sure that someone's going to have a great experience,
目前只有全职，好的，这是我们正在努力弄清楚如何做得更好的事情，这是远程办公的挑战之一。我们确实有，就像我说的，我们在旧金山有一个办公室，在多伦多有一个，但它们不是特别大。所以对于实习，我们总是想确保某人会有一个很棒的体验，
have a lot of support around them. Yeah, that makes sense. And so like, hey, be our intern, but just sit in your living room and like ping people on Slack. It's not the experience I would sign up for. Yep, yep. Personally. So we're the experience I would sign up for personally. So we're trying to figure out how to get there.
周围有很多支持。是的，这很有道理。所以就像，嘿，做我们的实习生，但只是坐在你的客厅里，在 Slack 上 ping 人。这不是我会注册的体验。是的，是的。就个人而言。所以我们是我会个人注册的体验。所以我们正在努力弄清楚如何到达那里。
Yeah, totally. Doing that at the moment. Cool. Well, Rob, thank you so much for coming on the show. I would ask for if you had student discounts, but it's totally free for students. Unless your project reaches PyTorch level popularity, in which case you should reach out to some venture capitalists or something like that.
是的，完全。目前正在做这件事。酷。好吧，Rob，非常感谢你来到节目。我会问你是否有学生折扣，但它对学生完全免费。除非你的项目达到 PyTorch 级别的流行度，在这种情况下，你应该联系一些风险投资家之类的。
Yeah, right. That's what you're supposed to do to discount. Yeah, exactly. So thank you so much for coming on the show. And if folks have questions, they know how to reach you. And I really appreciate it. Awesome. Thanks for having me.
是的，没错。这就是你应该做的折扣。是的，完全正确。所以非常感谢你来到节目。如果大家有疑问，他们知道怎么联系你。我真的很感激。太棒了。谢谢你邀请我。
It was tons of fun. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and sharealike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这非常有趣。介绍音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编作品，但你必须向 Patrick 和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。